[Music]
okay all right we're gonna see [ __ ]
christ god damn it all right i connected
the lan cable
it looks like ridiculous it did actually
it reached but i got everything
stretched out the depth one because it's
like all scratched off the [ __ ] i'm
gonna have to like i'm gonna have to get
an
extender and like going all over the
[ __ ] place
so we're not all wi-fi we're on a lan
cable so hopefully this will help
i mean we'll see how it goes we'll see
how it goes but i don't i don't i don't
honestly everything that i bought up to
this point has not worked so
i'm just i'm skeptical that anything
that i buy is gonna work
but i guess last time though at the old
house putting it on a land cable solved
a lot of [ __ ] it did yeah that's true
so i think i think but yeah but back at
the old house like my office was like
literally 10 feet away from the from the
router whereas now the router's way the
[ __ ] down the other side of the house
look at that [ __ ] it's standing [ __ ]
steady at 2200 yeah but it was doing
that before too so we'll see it looks a
lot steadier i mean forgive me if i'm
dubious yeah because i see
yeah jason said you could just get a
longer cable yeah i can't remember how
long this cable is i think it might be
20 or 30 feet
um and it just reached yeah but we can't
leave it like that because it's kind of
like in the way of everything don't have
to measure it out and get one that's
about five feet longer yeah we'll have
to we need one that's like about five or
ten five to ten feet longer and it'd be
great and then just when we stream i'll
just connect the [ __ ] land cable if
this does it and i've got a feeling and
this is that this this will do it yeah
we'll see
because i remember that last time when
we put land cable it [ __ ] solved a
lot of problems yeah because i mean it
was it was easier at our old house
because yeah it was close the router was
in the living room and my office was
like right off the living room so it was
like you know it was right there yeah um
yeah this house is much bigger and the
router is a lot farther away that data
stream looks a lot
more solid
wealthy
we'll see i mean
okay let's see i don't even know because
i talked for a long time before you said
that it wasn't even connected anymore
even though it told me it was still
connected
um so i don't even know if anybody heard
any of the stuff that we said about cat
videos or anything like that
you've been getting into those palace
cat videos yeah about yeah yeah zach
yeah
that french that french pop song that we
were thinking about was the one about
moreto
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i always forget the name of the song
and i always forget the name of the band
yeah it got that now french porn i could
find it again if i had to she's like a
french 80s early 80s porn star singing
and she does a great job on it i don't
remember i don't remember the name of
the song or her though now that he says
that french that 80s french pop song
it's probably the same one though
probably yeah
god i hate that [ __ ] song i think
it's just because it's not a bad song
objectively it's just that
it's one of those songs that like i feel
like he would play it at eyebar like
every saturday and i was just kind of
like this song again it's so long
and i was just kind of like ugh
not again and i was just kind of like i
don't know it just pissed me off but uh
yeah tom loves it though so every time
he would come on he'd be it would come
on and he'd be like yeah and i'd be like
and [ __ ] you
so it might be the same song i'm not
really sure i have had a couple people
ask me
what song that is i can't remember
the [ __ ] is the name of that song
i can't even i can't remember the name
of the song or the band
but i found it one time because i think
jen asked me about it one time she's
like what the [ __ ] is that song called
and i'd and i looked it up and i
remembered but uh you know i can't
remember it like offhand
um
i don't mind i listen to a lot of stuff
you know we listen to like a lot of
german stuff so a lot of that's you know
industrial stuff a lot of that's in
german uh so i like that and uh i like
old sugar cubes stuff who was bjork's
old band and one cool thing that they
did was that every time they would put
out a single
they would put the icelandic language
version of that single on the b side
which i thought was kind of
uh which i thought was kind of a cool
thing for them to do
so uh there's that there's actually some
french goth bands too although generally
they sing in english
interestingly best french goth band was
[ __ ] die form it was like goth
industrial fetish they were [ __ ]
really good yeah
yeah they were the last one they'd be
singing about [ __ ] bondage and
bestiality and [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] man weird
way ahead of their time i'm trying to
think there's actually uh
corpus delicti corpus de lecti
are i believe they're a french goth band
they generally sing in english they
might have had some that were in french
but they're really really good i like
them a lot but that was 90s i want to
say they're a 90s band
i think they're french
but there were a couple of other ones
but yeah like i said a lot of them kind
of do sing in english i guess you get
like a wider audience
uh if you sing in english rather than
your native language which
that's kind of sad but i i kind of feel
like
english is such a ubiquitous language
it's kind of hard to get away from uh
grant there's a singing do host
in the
in the comments
um
you know and there's an english version
of duhoust
and
it's not good it's it just sounds much
cooler in german
and
every now and then some dj will get it
in their head i'm going to play the
english language version of do hot like
everybody thinks it's the german version
everybody's like woohoo duhas and they
go out there although goths are just
kind of like oh god dude but you know
what i mean it's it's that so a lot of
people like go out to the dance floor
and then it like starts with english
words and everybody's like ah it's the
english language version nobody wants to
hear that
it sounds cooler in german well and like
i said i kind of feel like i'm real into
um
yeah bands like uh like dasic and uh
einsteins that don't know about and
stuff like that and
um there's a mostly in german but if you
look don't ever look up like english
translations of
lyrics
like of dasic songs or answers einster's
internet mountain songs because it
sounds really really dumb in english but
in german it sounds like pretty cool so
there's that
uh zach says i wonder if i should brush
up on my french before my trek to
louisiana because my uncle lives out in
the
boonies there's nobody speaking french
out there anymore really nah
no
i took french for four years and it's
like i kind of remember some of it but
not a great deal
a lot of times if i see a movie that's
in french i'll understand about
20 of what they're saying
but it's been a while
john smith says i miss 90s goth the crow
has a lot to answer for lol yeah
honestly i'm more like i said i'm more
kind of into
late 70s early 80s
post punk goth rock death rock i like
that kind of stuff
that once once it started going more
into like the ethereal direction i
really didn't like when it was going
more toward graver
or
more industrial i do like some
industrial
but
a lot of it was just kind of like samey
to me and once everything kind of
started going in those two directions i
kind of lost interest to a great deal
but there are a lot of like good bands
that came out in the 90s i will say
um you know like i said corpus delicti
being one of them but corpus delective
sounded more like
a death rock band to me they sounded
more like
you know what i mean they sounded kind
of more like a a rock band as opposed to
industrial or
you know or electro or whatever
because i'm that's i'm not a big fan of
that of elektra
or [ __ ] i like some of it but
i don't know i kind of feel like most of
the clubs went that way
in the 90s and i was kind of over it
you know yeah i'm trying to find what
that [ __ ] die form album was
that i used to listen to
man that [ __ ] it's not here
um
they are a good band though yeah yeah
but that's
i want to say that's a little bit more
like on the ethereal goths side because
i do kind of feel like well 90s that was
kind of like the big thing of you had
kind of like all this like crunchy
industrial music with like this ethereal
like angelic like female vocals on it
that was a big thing in the 90s i have
like several compilation albums of like
nothing but that yeah okay i found it
was called lamy electric electric
okay
yeah
let me see if i can uh
and jason willie brings up the craft
i still love that movie furrysabach was
like cute as [ __ ] in that yeah um
i mean she's still cute as [ __ ] we saw
her a couple of years ago with the yeah
that horror convention
she still looked pretty much the same i
mean i recognized her immediately she
was skinny from like across the room and
i was like hey that's for roosevelt
right she still looks pretty much the
same but um
[Music]
zach says uh
i'm surprised there wasn't a lot of
gotha from the 70s with how dark and
grimy feeling a lot of the movies from
then feel there well there was but
nobody called it that they didn't really
call it that
nothing was really called gothic rock i
think the doors were called gothic rock
to be fair yeah but it wasn't like a
thing
um it it really didn't become a thing
until like the late 70s i feel like and
then maybe like susan the banshees got
called that like joy division called it
got called that um so then it kind of
started to become a label
um
but there was some stuff that sounded
like that
what you would recognize today is record
like goth or goth adjacent but they
didn't call it that
if you want to hear a good album it's
that one by die form and everything on
that album
it's bizarre it's kind of industrial it
has operatic female vocals in that
really
hard male industrial vocals
kind of laid over it it's just a real
kana
driving and but kind of spooky album
it's real good
really good
yeah they still get played in clubs
every now and then yeah
every now and then
but uh yeah i'm trying to like think of
some other
i thought there was like another french
band that i really liked like another
goth band but i can't think of who they
are i mean corpus delicti was the main
one i'm pretty sure they're french i
mean if you have time like look them up
on wikipedia i'm pretty sure they're
french though but they as far as i know
they mainly uh sang in english
who was that other band
um there was a bank called suspiria but
i don't were they french
[ __ ] now i can't remember they were good
too they had a weird accent but i'm not
really sure if they're french though but
they usually sang in english also
um
rebecca said i watched once upon a time
in hollywood last night for the first
time
i was thoroughly amused and it takes a
lot for me to enjoy a comedy honestly i
really really dug that movie we saw that
uh i think we did we see that twice in
the theater i think we might have
once butter time in hollywood
and then i and then i got it on blue and
then i bought it for you
for your birthday or christmas or
something like that great movie
i really did i like that it's kind of
like a hangout movie
because it doesn't really get like
[ __ ] up until like toward the end
but honestly i was kind of like into the
hanging out i just really liked the
characters it's actually one of the few
um
one of the few tarantino movies that i
liked most of his movies i don't really
like that much
i only like maybe
one third of them
but i mean that's a pretty good swinging
average or batting average if you want
to say it like that his best movie he
didn't direct he i think he just wrote
it's called true romance i really liked
that one you know what that popped up
other day on
uh
might have been 2b or might have been
hulu yeah and so because i meant to tell
you i was like oh true romance came up
on the thing like if you want to watch
it like maybe we should review it but i
don't remember which streaming service
it came up on but i noticed it
john smith says going to see the damned
later this year for the original lineup
reunion holy [ __ ]
how awesome would that be honestly the
damned
i even like some of their like [ __ ] that
came out in the 2000s where they went a
little bit more i want to say they went
kind of psychabilly but that's okay i
like that too edius is i'll check it out
tom you got good taste since you got me
to corey i love corey and i was
listening to corey last night
they actually played we missed them in
tampa yeah wednesday night when we were
doing the show yeah i had totally
forgotten like i did the poster yeah so
i knew they were coming and i told tom
oh we should go see them even though
tampa is kind of far but i still think
maybe i would have gone on a wednesday i
probably have gone but i forgot about it
i thought they were coming up here to uh
i thought they were coming up here to
play
at what you call it will's pub
now a starry night are coming to will's
pub
not tomorrow but next saturday yeah so
we're definitely taking some videos
we'll show them on the show we'll
definitely go to that yeah uh so yeah
it's been it's been a while since
they've been up here i got actually i
had forgotten and then imani sent me a
message that they were coming because
she's going
and she was like you know because i
haven't seen her in forever i feel like
i haven't seen anybody in forever yeah
but if you want to start on diet form
that album i just showed you that's a
good one to start with it was from the
uh 90s
la me
electrique
it's something french i can't pronounce
it
i don't know what they're talking about
i don't even know what a lame is well
wait is it l apostrophe l-a-m-e oh lem
lem
lim something like that electric i think
that means
mostly i love or
the love or something like that i can't
remember it's been a long time most of
the lyrics are in english
but uh but the title of that album isn't
and it you they used to have that whole
album up on youtube but it seems to be
missing it looks like most of it's on
youtube right now
uh but then they got their other albums
are up there they're real [ __ ] they
had really good videos
that that female vocalist i don't
remember what her name was but she was
like really 90s looking [ __ ] fetish
goth with a little
bob hair cut look like something from
the 1920s and
she had a really good opera voice and
did a lot of nude work in the videos a
lot of art like bauhaus looking and
expressionism and weird [ __ ] happening
and snakes wrapped around them and
they did a lot of [ __ ] in france that
you couldn't do here in the u.s i
remember
uh well france loves their smut yeah
[Laughter]
but
my friend john from sleep chamber john's
whis from sleep chamber told me about
him that's how i learned about him and
and he was [ __ ]
him and the barbiturates they were all
into that weird fetish stuff and he'd
get all these [ __ ]
photographs from fans and [ __ ] coming to
him and
bizarre man [ __ ] anyway uh just
he said that uh
he said that [ __ ] they did a show in
france at one time and [ __ ] they
brought some chick out the [ __ ] dog
jumped on her and [ __ ] having sex
with her on the stage it was
but i probably you know this it was
probably only semi-simulated kind of
like the way
uh what do you call it
um jan from jenna torturers because did
she did all kinds of crazy [ __ ] too we
run into her we ran into her a couple
times well she's from around she's from
here and uh
when you meet her she's [ __ ] real
friendly she's nice it's all just part
of the stage act you know but they're
into the life she used to shop at judy's
jazzy boutique in daytona beach because
i used to hang out there when i was a
kid yeah
and uh every time i went in there
they're like oh jen was in here the
other day and she said this that near
then she bought this and then the other
side you know yeah it was a whole thing
and she's cute too she's a good-looking
girl good-looking girl
she's our age didn't she
we gotta be or older or older maybe i
mean because i kind of feel like i was
seeing them live
going back to
[ __ ] when i was just out of high school
so that must be
early to mid 90s if you don't know jenna
torturers
it's a good fetish
florida fetish goth industrial band
they're best to see live because their
live shows are like really
entertaining the best album to start off
with that is [ __ ] uh um jenna
tortures 120 days and sodom i think is
the name of it or 120 days of jenna
torture yeah 120 days
i have a shirt of that yeah
let me see um
rebecca says i'm still listening to the
lost boys soundtrack cry little sister
never gets old yeah you know what uh
paul vane just played that at mannequins
when we were there last friday matter of
fact when we were sitting when we first
just got there like early in the night
he played it
yeah
but uh i i used to have that soundtrack
on cassette i still love the lost boys
that's a great [ __ ] movie it's one of
the best uh vampire movies i'm not super
into vampire [ __ ] but you know
that's the genus orders album you want
to start with yeah that's that's jen
yeah i have a shirt with that on it yeah
in some places
it's a real good album
i mean if you're into it's kind of
um i don't know i kind of feel like the
jenna tortures that's like better like i
said it's better to see them live
their albums are good but
you kind of need the visuals to
accompany it hey there's a ladybug in
here look at that
oh yeah
you know what's weird there was a i
wonder is that the same ladybug
because yesterday i was brushing my hair
over there at the mirror and i was like
oh there's a ladybug like crawling up
the mirror
and i thought pokey would have killed it
but i guess not maybe that's the same
one hey ladybug
what's up
yeah everybody's talking about how good
true romance is yeah it's good that's my
favorite i mean i'm pretty sure that
just came up like on a streaming service
the other day yeah because i wanted to
tell you about it because i know you
like that movie a lot
john smith said i'd recommend the
awesome damned documentary don't you
wish that we were dead okay now i have
to see that because
you know
uh let's see always with the bots yeah
french smut
i'll tell you what that stream is
[ __ ]
real solid
yeah i mean i guess we're gonna have to
do that then yep
that's what it is well like i said i had
the cable hooked up to the the booster
yeah but that really didn't seem to be
making much difference because it had a
thing where you could hook it up to the
booster it must have something to do
with the memory
that this thing has when it comes to the
upload speed
it can't keep up with it
i guess must be what it is we're too
much for the internet too much too much
for that laptop or something
rebecca says it's not even 9 30 a.m here
and now i have the image of bestiality
in my head yeah so here we go yeah
[ __ ] um
can i just say okay so this is weird
[ __ ] man this is gonna be a little while
before this goes up
but
i don't remember which one of you it was
but it's probably one of you
[ __ ] that's in there right now
who was it that recommended to me the
book cows
tell me right now it was a good book i'm
gonna say that right now but holy [ __ ]
that was one of the grossest [ __ ]
things i've ever read in my entire
[ __ ] life
i don't know why i didn't i don't know
how i didn't barf while i was reading it
but it is good
uh but i recorded a review for it today
which hopefully you will find
entertaining although it's not going up
for
well let me see
the book review i did for
this monday was like actually a vampire
novel
so it'll be up the monday after that
because i try to keep like a week ahead
on my movie and uh book reviews i don't
always succeed but i do try to
so i've already so i've already got the
book review for next week and the two
movie reviews for next week already
recorded and the book review for the
week after that already recorded
and
i'm trying to think oh and i watched
cloverfield today i've seen it before
but i watched it again and because i'm
gonna review them for my monster uh
monster movie thing
would you do a show about the knights
templar and the illuminati you know what
um we did one that was kind of about the
illuminati um
i think didn't we i thought we did and i
kept putting up like knights templar and
illuminati like in the patreon poll and
it really never seemed to win
but i'm pretty sure we did do an
illuminati show at some point i don't
remember how good it was
because it was a while back but you know
uh
yeah so uh cheryl says cows yeah it's um
it's a book from 1994 and it's kind of
uh pretty well known in sort of like
extreme fiction
circles
as being like
one of the pretty much grossest things
that you can read which
i mean there's a lot of really gross
[ __ ] out there i'm not a huge um pro
like advocate or you know reader of
extreme fiction i have read quite a bit
of it
it's not my favorite genre but i'm not
averse to it uh it's not the grossest
thing i've ever read but it's uh it's
definitely in the top five i'll i'll say
that um yeah it made me like pretty
nauseated like reading it i gotta say
and that that's that takes a lot so
that's that's a lot coming from me
sounds interesting i'm yeah um
um
i don't know well how do you feel how do
you feel about
uh
poop eating because there's a lot of
that going on in it and uh there's a lot
of like bestiality like animal rape uh
there's just all kind of stuff
so
it's it's a whole thing and i know that
people i found this um
book this book reviewing channel the
[ __ ] is it called
uh
[ __ ] i can't remember his name is juan
and
[ __ ]
something by visions paralyzed by
visions something like that you know
what they'd like to get away we could
just have another one of these routers
[ __ ] put in up here well yeah acid
ask them if they know
somebody must know can we just have
another [ __ ]
i mean wi-fi router up here i don't know
you could probably pay right
i don't know you don't have to have just
one
yeah it's like lay's potato chips yeah
uh cheryl says who's the author of cows
matthew stoko
s-t-o-k-o-e
if you have kindle unlimited you can
read it for free right now which is what
i did
um like i said uh
all the trigger warnings for it i'm
gonna tell you right now it's uh it's
pretty [ __ ] gross so john smith said
what's the grossest thing you've ever
read
uh this book i was just talking about
it's up there
um although i will say i kind of feel
like and i'm gonna give it to the og
like marquis de sade some of that shit's
grosser
but this was pretty [ __ ] gross gotta
say
it's pretty [ __ ] gross
um
gramther says my 11 month old brittany
puppy eats her poops then wants to kiss
yeah i mean you know
you got to love them but holy [ __ ]
i don't know and i and i said this in
the review too look i don't have any
problem at all with gore okay i don't
give a [ __ ] about like you can cut limbs
off all day long you can eviscerate
people you can
do whatever
um you can do like some other [ __ ] that
i heard from some other book where they
stick like dynamite sticks in people's
asses and blow their anuses apart it's
fine it's like i don't i don't care
that does not gross me out but the
second people start eating poop
uh or eating vomit or something like
that i'm out i'm out that just
plagued my visions thank you that's what
that is
um
that is a great [ __ ] channel i don't
know why it took me so long because i'm
i subscribe to like a lot of other like
book reviewers that are horror you know
that focus on horror
and i don't know why it took so long for
that one to come up because that's a
great [ __ ] channel that guy
is
i mean and his videos are like really
really long and they're really in-depth
and he takes like a really long time and
he's obviously like read very very
widely
and
i mean i don't know i just found his
stuff like really really uh
fascinating
and he's just like he's very very well
spoken very well researched and he's
read like everything
so i don't know i don't know why it took
so long for that to come up with my
recommendations but there it is so i
finally like subscribed to him so i was
watching his video today which was the
10 most disgusting books that he'd ever
read and i said notably the 10 most
disgusting books he'd ever read cows was
on there but it was not in the top ten
it was only in the um
in the uh what do you call it the uh
honorable mentions
so that should tell you something but
cows i'm gonna say it's pretty [ __ ]
gross it's pretty [ __ ] gross
um
i didn't
ever not want to finish it but when i
was reading it at some point i had to
like skim through it because i said i
think i'm going to puke if i keep
reading this so
i'm just going to like i you know taylor
just jumped in well hey yeah
there we go what's up t cheryl said i
bookmarked it i'll read it okay
don't say i didn't worry though because
i mean it might not bother you but
to me she said tom you've seen brubacher
watch it last night brubacher that was
um
that was uh
that was burt reynolds if i remember
correctly i've seen that movie but it's
been a long time i saw that in the
drive-in or no i saw that in the matinee
in mississippi for the summer
that was a night like maybe 82 83 maybe
i think i don't remember much about it
you're gonna have to refresh my memory
but i remember liking that one i'm
telling you man
the reynolds the reynolds and when he
was in his prime
the reynolds the reynolds reynolds the
browns the reynolds we have to call him
that when the reynolds was
when reynolds was in his trap in his
prime in the 70s and the early 80s he
was the [ __ ] now he did make a comeback
with the [ __ ] damn [ __ ] porn movie
when he came back as an old dude he was
real good in that too [ __ ] yeah what
was the name of that movie uh
one where he was in a yeah i know boogie
nights [ __ ] he came back and boogie
nights god damn it i love bookings yeah
that's another good one i mean
bruno's could act but he always kind of
played himself
uh but he was just a a southern a
southern classic a southern original
straight straight from [ __ ] well now
all that stuff was like uh good and
everything but bonnie [ __ ] him up just
ran off with all his money left him
alone tila said brew baker uh no it was
robert redford robert
all right what's what's what do you know
about robert redford oh i've seen some
of his oh man he did good movies too
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] condor did was it
five days of the condor
three days three days the condor the
book was called
a great movie yeah he had a lot of good
movies i'll check it out brew baker
redford all right i'll check it out
was he a paper moon paper
or was that what no no he wasn't a paper
mop oh that was uh that was that other
that was yeah
um that's a good movie though too i want
to see paper moon again i remember i
remember liking that as kids black and
white movie about depression
old griffer running around with his
daughter and they're running these scabs
that's how i remembered it good movie
um
yeah what am i thinking of
there was a movie that was ryan o'neill
because it was ryan o'neal and tatum
o'neill yeah yeah but i'm talking about
i don't know why there was a bert
reynolds movie
i think it had something to do with
racing
that's not really narrowing it down
i gotta confuse the brubaker
you guys know which movie i'm talking
about uh stroker ace oh stroker stroker
ace yes
yeah
uh dj maniac says uh i'm in the latest
issue of procession magazine this month
that's pretty awesome honestly uh
procession
magazine i think they're one of the
sponsors
of the absolution festival here in tampa
which uh if you don't know if you're
ever in the tampa area right around
halloween time or early october it
usually is
uh it's a three-day
is it three days this year or it's
usually three days i don't know if it's
three days or two days this year but
it's um a festival of all kind of like
uh mostly death rock and goth rock bands
and we've gone for the last couple years
and it's always like a really good uh
really good time
corrine plays there starry night plays
there all kind of like really cool
[ __ ] bands play there john smith says
speaking of books and extreme stuff
cormac mccarthy has two new books coming
out this year that's what i heard and
honestly i just heard that today because
i was watching a video earlier about the
like a cormac mccarthy like super fan
and he was talking about how everyone's
super jazzed about like his new books
coming out i still need to read i've
read the road which was yeah one of the
most soul-crushing things ever i still
need to read blood meridian though
because i feel like that's the one that
everybody recommends
and i still haven't gotten around to
reading that but i eventually will
there's so much stuff i gotta it's just
like movies i gotta say i got a big pile
tila is advising the ladies that
reference was looking real good in that
movie
um
yeah redford you know back in the day of
course you know [ __ ] my mother's
generation [ __ ] they love robert
river all right
uh even uh
i've seen a lot of stuff that david
bowie did during that era and you could
see the bow he was getting real
robert redford-esque and with his style
so i think bowie was a robert redford
[ __ ] fan
he was doing the visual cues and [ __ ]
from reverend yeah but we
bowie actually
we consider himself an entertainer but
he actually wanted to be an actor more
than anything else bowie was a very good
actor people don't people don't realize
that i mean i liked him in everything
he's very good
he's great in the hunger yep he's great
in man who fell to earth yep uh
labyrinth uh have you guys seen a movie
called the linguine incident yeah i
remember that one that was good uh
rosanna arquette absolute beginners
yeah absolutely beginners he was good in
that he was good in a lot of [ __ ] bowie
was uh bowie was
a serious actor real good
but he
made his name in music entertainment and
it's hard to back off of that because
that's where his fans were
but i mean the cool thing about bowie
was that he was so versatile yeah that
cuz you know how
sometimes um you get like rock stars and
they're good at being rock stars but
then they're like oh then they want to
be in movies and everything like just
just stop it stop it
um i don't think anybody did that for
bowie though no
you know what i mean we wanted to be an
actor primarily what i understand is
that that which i can yeah i can see
that's kind of like his whole time yeah
well his whole like uh
you know his whole persona was
characters characters and like doing
different roles like for his different
so that was like totally in his
wheelhouse yeah so i don't think so i
think that's why people probably didn't
think it was strange no when he wanted
to be in movies because they're like oh
well of course well there were many
times in interviews where they called
him a musician he corrected him he says
i'm not a musician i'm an entertainer
you know because he's not a musician he
can play in musical instruments but
that's not what he considered himself
well in musician
i mean there's nothing wrong with being
a musician but it is very limiting yeah
well a musician really when you say i'm
a musician
uh really what you're talking about is
being a studio musician those guys were
[ __ ] fantastic
you know what i mean so you give them
all the credit in the world you know
carlos alamar was a [ __ ] musician you
know the dudes from [ __ ]
steely dan were musicians
all right
that's not what bowie was bowie was
about bringing you a [ __ ] show
and characters and telling a story i
mean there's a difference between a
musician very different and like a rock
star right because some of the people
that are rock stars are not really
musicians can't really play or they
can't you know read music or anything
like that but they're just like really
good at entertaining entertaining yeah
uh a perfect example that would have
been
um
sid vicious couldn't play his way out of
a [ __ ] paper bag but he was
entertaining and left his mark he was
the entertainer yeah people still
remember him i remember right this many
decades later right even though he
couldn't play where the show couldn't
play where he could play like one
yeah he could play one ramone's baseline
yeah that was about it but that was good
enough it was good enough he pulled it
off he he looked good he invented kind
of the got the proto-goth male look
that's really where a lot of the [ __ ]
goth aesthetic came from that and uh i'm
gonna and i'm gonna say that on the back
that on the back of [ __ ] john
lightner johnny rotten said that his
look was goth and johnny light couldn't
stand it he hated that look of course he
did
player hate you know
if you john lyden was just mad because
he said [ __ ] was better looking than
him if you liked it then john lyden was
going to [ __ ] on it that's just how it
was
that was his thing though and to be
honest i'm not
i mean when i was younger like people
like that were funny but the older i get
like the more tiresome people like that
are yeah
[Laughter]
they just like you're not allowed to
like anything you're not allowed to be
gen you'd have genuine feelings about
anything they're just gonna like make
fun or you know just [ __ ] on you for it
i'm just kind of like
you know taylor brings up the cher was a
good actress too yeah she was good she
was absolutely good yeah
she was good so is that so is that
moonstruck was great uh mask was great
yeah
with eric stultz so is that chick that
[ __ ] um
ripped off [ __ ] dale bozier from
missing persons what's her name
um
uh
lady gaga lady gaga lady gaga can act
i'll give her that she could act now i
haven't seen house of gucci yet
probably good we haven't seen it but
i've heard mixed reviews yep um
but i don't know it looked we saw the
trailers great the star was born god
damn she was fantastic in that she was
really fantastic
that was an awesome movie to be honest
and that's not usually the type of movie
that i'm that i'm super into
and i've seen the other because that
movie's been remade like a zombie yeah
that's a little hollywood classic it is
classic
but i don't know i kind of dug it yeah i
thought i thought it was really great
they did a [ __ ] good job and that was
uh that was bradley cooper wasn't the
same guy that was in uh nightmare alley
that was the same guy you probably
didn't recognize him because
but that's the same dude though i'm the
only straight man who loves musicals
well i don't know if you're the only
straight man but you're the only
straight man that will admit to it i
[ __ ] love you
yeah gayer those musicals are the more i
love them
i should show you gays love it then i'm
gonna love it
i like musicals too like well up to a
point i don't like some of them are i
find annoying but honestly most of them
i don't i don't mind them i kind of like
weird ass musicals like i said i like
rocky horror picture little little shop
of horrors yeah um hedwig and the angry
inch i don't remember didn't see that uh
i have the dvd grease i love grease i
also love grease too xanadu is good um
and honestly
greece too i kind of feel like oh people
like guilty pleasure i'm not guilty
about it yeah i love that [ __ ]
phantom appearance i've seen it about
400 times yeah i should probably show
you
uh hedvig and the angry inch you might
like it it's honestly it's kind of about
uh
it was what was it what was the other
one that was [ __ ] good [ __ ] demon
barber barber demons oh yeah yeah what
was his name uh sweden todd great
musical yeah they did a good until like
uh you know tim burton did a good job
with that i gotta say yeah um
i gotta say [ __ ] um repo genetic
opera real good he didn't like it that
much but [ __ ] repo genetic opera that
was a good goth industrial musical
they still play [ __ ] they still play
that [ __ ] song at the yeah club yeah
pretty much every week yeah zydra didn't
add an exaggerated anatomy song yeah
that's a good one yeah that they play
that there's a lot of good musicals even
though when did that movie come out 2008
yeah i think it was 2008. it's classical
2008 or 2011. i can't remember but it's
been a while
i liked i liked [ __ ] xanadu want to
see that again i did as well yeah
i liked
sergeant pepper's lily hearts clubbing
oh great one yeah we got to see that
again it's so yeah we got one the one
with the bg's yeah yeah yeah and george
burns yeah and alice cooper yeah and
aaron and aerosmith yeah who else was in
that like [ __ ]
the live television version of greece
was good had bell biv devoe isn't it
they did the [ __ ] beauty school
dropout remember that and then that was
i was impressed that actually was very
very live television yeah they did it
live it came on it came on my uh
grease
album it came grease one and the live
television version that came out
together we we actually were excited
about it and we watched it live watched
it live and then on fox or whoever the
hell did it yeah and i was really
impressed i was like wow that came out
really really good i heard they did the
rocky horror picture show and i missed
it
but from everybody like i talked to
people afterwards like was that any good
and people were like no it wasn't any
good another another one i'm still kind
of curious to watch it another one
that's just gay as [ __ ] i [ __ ] love
it [ __ ] my fair lady i [ __ ] love
that one my fair lady is awesome my fair
lady is great yeah that's awesome yeah
that's good tom it's like that's good
yeah that's your embrace good song
you're embracing your feminine side it's
not feminine though it's just musicals
we'll see that's what i mean it's not
feminine i don't understand why musicals
are coded
feminine yeah i don't know it's not
feminine that seems very strange it's
just they're very popular they're very
popular
with men they're popular with the gay
crowd
yeah you know the show tunes and [ __ ]
they're probably
look but here's the deal me and jenny go
to gay clubs to go to tran club [ __ ]
clubs [ __ ] you know on goth
industrial nights and [ __ ] goth [ __ ]
happens in [ __ ] [ __ ] and gay clubs
it's all that underground [ __ ]
so
the crowds mix
you know you're gonna [ __ ] meet all
kinds of cool people that like all kinds
of [ __ ]
so
i don't know it's it's funny like
that [ __ ] would never fly over at a
biker bar they would appreciate it
they don't have that they're not they're
not cultured enough to understand that
you know
they just like country music
yeah and the younger ones like [ __ ]
metal
which like i said it's like kind of
limited way i mean people like what they
like yeah i'm not gonna like [ __ ] on
people for liking what they like but um
i don't think that you should like [ __ ]
on something that you're not
exposed to or that you haven't seen
because you might have you might see it
and you might like it
cheryl says she hasn't seen sergeant
peppers
oh you gotta rent that [ __ ] tonight
sergeant pepper says great okay look
okay
is nothing but beatles songs but done by
not the beatles done by other people
most of them starring the bee gees and
the bad guys are like the [ __ ]
aerosmith and a couple of other bands
and they're telling this wacky ass
[ __ ] story it's like
it's like one it's like a story
musical story made up of [ __ ] of
beetles of beetles songs kind of
it's good though it's real good i mean
it's not objectively it's not good it's
fun but i love it it's fun i still love
it i mean i saw it when i was a kid it
was on cable a zillion times back in the
70s when did it come at 78 it's robert
stigwood just think of it he did a lot
of uh musicals and that kind of [ __ ]
back then just think of it as a
as a beatles
tribute album but it's music videos
by a bunch of bands
and it's disco but it does have a story
it does have a story i mean right the
story being the bee gees
are playing a band
called sergeant pepper's lonely heart
skill but that's what they're called
right and they're from a town which i
think is called heartland or something i
haven't seen in a while
and there are there's this whole thing
about there's these golden instruments
and then
this bad guy yeah uh
mr mustard he's the bad guy right yeah
yeah and then he steals the [ __ ] and
also he has robots
um
it's a it's a lot
someone was like i when they wrote it
but
they're trying to like cram in like a
bunch of really weird like uh beatles
lyrics you know the beatles also
probably were high when they wrote most
of stuff so they're trying to like put
it into a narrative
and
i don't know there's just something
really
comforting about it i don't know what it
is i just really really like it
objectively it's a terrible movie but
i don't know i'm kind of like into it
grantham's in there tom and i were in a
musical together true it is true yeah
[ __ ] ex-soldiers the next cops when
we were kids we were in a musical
together i thought we were in two we
were both in pip and then and in uh
and and joseph and the amazing
technicolor dreamcoat i think we were in
both of those weren't we
i think the only musicals i was i was in
showboat when i was younger
um i was in annie
yeah
um
i'm trying to think i was mostly i was
in the chorus
so
i was mostly we did like chorus [ __ ]
tila said not a friend of repo but fan
where the paradise is on okay look
repo
takes a couple of viewings
i think the third time i saw repo that's
when i really got into it it the first
time it seemed off
like it didn't flow that well
you got to watch it a couple times it's
it's it's addictive um
but yeah then t goes on about how good
sergeant peppers is sergeant peppers is
[ __ ] great and there's something i
really i love that some about it being
retro and kind of cheap that helps it
when you're truck
or
or you're slightly like not in your
rights like if you're under the
influence of some
it makes it so much better because it's
just these old
cover songs by the bee gees and it's
just
it's probably better now than it was
back in the late 70s early 80s when it
came out because it's just
well now you get like the retro you get
the retro vibe sure
it's a great it's a great movie
for what it is
think of it as
a cover album a tribute album to the
beatles
by disco and rock bands from the 70s
yeah and it's music videos showing you
in music video terms
i mean alice cooper and the robots
singing yes because yeah great
there was some about those [ __ ] shiny
black female sex bots they were gold
actually i thought they were they were
black i'm pretty sure they were no they
were [ __ ] gloss black some they had
gold highlights on them but they were
gloss black
and
it was very fetishy i was like as a kid
i was going man that's kind of hot
those [ __ ] robots i don't know what
it was
it was weird camp guy talks about west
side story yeah i do love it i also live
west side story i mean there's a lot of
musicals i like actually i like weird
musicals but i like regular musicals too
my creative calling my creepy phone is
uh ringing again john smith says i love
musicals but that cats movie that came
out a few years ago was a bit much for
me yeah i heard we didn't see it enough
but i heard that it was like kind of uh
[ __ ] cats pretty weird or like uncanny
value the original cats wasn't any good
evidently cats wasn't even really all
that good to see on stage from what i
understand well i mean well i don't know
about that because like 40 bajillion
people saw it well you have to think it
was based on
t.s eliot's book of practical cats which
wasn't even really a it wasn't a novel
or anything it was just kind of like t
brings up sound of music i haven't seen
it in so long i gotta check that one out
again i saw it in high school uh we
watched it in our uh in our chorus becca
brings up olivia newton john and xanadu
and twist of fate
i want to come back my new life looking
like her she was so gorgeous yeah olivia
living john was looking beautiful and
that that was a great movie i want to
see that one again did not buy that
isn't that on blu-ray or did we stream
that
we uh i'm pretty sure we rented it okay
i want that [ __ ] on blu-ray
that's a good me i want a lot of those
musicals on blu-ray now that i'm
thinking about it you can just pop them
in and watch them i like having a hard
copy of things
yeah and wicked lee says uh when you
said that uh only gay men like musical
or you said something like that how
would you and he said wrong i love
musicals yeah elizabeth judy garland and
i'm straight super straight in fact yeah
yeah like i said i'm joking when i talk
about yeah and honestly i kind of feel
like it's so [ __ ] reductive to just
say oh that's like a woman and you know
what i mean it's like every bit come on
everybody likes me as yes i like that
you admit that you like musicals because
a lot of straight dudes still even in
2022
because you know some dudes egos are
very fragile i guess um will not admit
that they like musicals come on
now i'm gonna be the first to say though
that
one genre of film that i do not like and
i'm a girl
is
rom-coms or chick-flicks i do not like
those there's a few no i have to like i
have seen some that i like yeah but in
general
i do not like them and i don't usually
watch them i'm a horror girl that one
that we saw that was with the fat girl
what's her name and they were oh right
right yeah they found rom-coms that was
great i mean yeah that was that was
actually really what was the name of
that movie what the [ __ ] was the name of
that girl
that was uh it was rebel rebel rebel
williams
wilson
it was funny she's [ __ ] knocked out
wasn't she knocked out or something she
was in a coma or something where she was
in an alternate universe yeah and
everything was a [ __ ] rom-com
yeah she's playing the wrong con game
that was great we saw that in the
theater
yeah that one was actually pretty
hilarious because it was it was bagging
all the wrong cops but it was still kind
of like a feel-good movie i mean it was
still a rom-com but it was like playing
with the tropes of the wrong yeah you
know what i mean now when i woke up this
morning i said man i want a [ __ ]
feel-good movie when i woke up so you
know i watched fighting with my family
about paige oh is that what you were
watching okay cause i could i heard
something yelling from the other room
yeah
pew miss pew i watched it again that's
probably the fifth time i've seen it
and that's a great movie and the the
blu-ray has the director's cut which is
a lot better than the than the
theatrical cut
i know tila said she was going to see it
she put it on her list
if there's any way you can see the the
director's cut of it
when you rent it that's
they're both good but the director's cut
is better
there's a lot more in it because they're
not really like they're not crushed for
time
but that's a great movie liked it
sorry i had to i had to acknowledge dj
maniac
making a kids in the hall reference i
see you there yeah podcast number one in
the charts bell biv devoe number one in
the charts bell bib to vote yeah that's
a that's a kids in the hall reference i
guess so i see you i see you there
um also zach says meanwhile i'm gay as
[ __ ] and i hate musicals
well like i said a yankee gay card
everybody's different you can't just
like you can't just say across the board
oh gay men love musicals or this that
and the other because i've met several
gay men it's a stereotype that do not
like music this is a stereotype oh
it's a stereotype and we'll get rob
halford on you
rob will [ __ ] you up because rob liked
musicals
he likes music i mean like i mean
musicals it's kind of it's a thing like
i said i don't think it it's not
gendered in any way it's just kind of
like you either like them or you don't
it's tribal art form people singing and
dancing and telling a story that's
tribal some people that's like going
back my grandma used to say to me yeah
that she didn't she's a woman and she
did not like musicals because she's like
well i just want to see him telling a
story i don't understand why suddenly
they start singing and [ __ ]
she would say something like that
she's like i just can't she couldn't get
behind
she's like i couldn't buy it like
they're just like they're having a
regular ass story and then everybody
starts singing and then she's like yeah
i'm out cheryl just said she got
midsummer in the mail she loved it so
much she had to buy it yeah midsummer is
a good movie i liked it
jason brings up hairspray that's another
great one yeah
the ricky lake one actually the remake
wasn't too bad either the one with john
travolta as the mom
uh that was actually a little bit better
than i was expecting although obviously
the john waters original is
way way better i'd have to say my
favorite musical in terms of movies
on top of them all be grease grease one
i've seen grease like so many [ __ ]
you can just put grease in and like and
and and jam with gent you're jamming out
to greece
well about teenage love the teenage love
angle and the singing and just you know
the
in that reality
so good yeah the songs in that are so
good every single song in that is
hopelessly devoted amazing which is
they're not in the original play i don't
think i think that they added that and
the original play was much dirtier yeah
yeah so the movie kind of toned it down
now if you want a really good horror
musical
it's [ __ ] sweeney todd i [ __ ]
that's a really good i could watch that
too
i could watch that all day like i said
tim burton did do a good job
tim burton
hit has hits and misses
sometimes he gets to tim burton e you
know yeah but um but now sweeney todd
was [ __ ] off a chain that was a good
one
and um oh what's his name
oh boy
what am i saying johnny depp johnny depp
johnny depp [ __ ] brings it
he brings it and he's [ __ ] scary in
that
he's just this smoldering [ __ ]
psychopath released from prison with the
[ __ ] hell bent on vengeance for the
[ __ ] that they did to his [ __ ] wife
and him
and then he finds them and then the
child and everything oh man all the
different layers of all this everybody's
throwing yeah and then they're becoming
cannibals and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
that was a badass movie i thought it was
just victorian london i saw that in the
theater yeah
and uh let's see
uh tila says the chick flick i love to
death is thelma and louise
same
thelma louise i don't even know
technically is that a chick flick i
guess it is but
honestly i don't know i don't know if
i'd call it a chick flick but that i
mean someone louise is [ __ ] awesome
that is like such a [ __ ] great tell
you if
t
[ __ ] singing hopelessly devoted in it
t if you if you [ __ ] like mid-summer
man go see fighting with my family
you'll like that movie it's good
it's that same girl pew she's in it
she plays paige the wrestler and it's
the her life story and all the [ __ ]
that they went through and
it's kind of a feel-good movie the rocks
in it
and uh and it's it's filmed right here
where near where me and jenny used to
[ __ ] hang out all the time when it's
[ __ ] it's cool because she's sitting
up in the damn window of her apartment
training to be a wrestler looking down
[ __ ] uh looking down the freeway to
me and jenny go across all the time it's
very much because i was like hey i
recognize that
very much a florida movie
about a british girl who ends up in
florida
to become a [ __ ] wrestler and uh
it's just it's just a good one of the
things about it is it's kind of cool
when you show florida it's kind of a
truism
nothing in orlando is old everything is
new
the city well because you know uh 50
years ago everything was like a swamp
nothing was here
everything's new pretty much
so and uh
it's just a different feel here you know
and then that film kind of captured it
another good florida movie would be
painting game i'm gonna watch that one
probably tomorrow
that's another one's got the rock in it
painting games are [ __ ] great with
mark wahlberg
he's in it it's based on a true story
another one based on true story about a
murder that took place there these
[ __ ] idiot ass muscle heads
it [ __ ] killed some dude trying to
make money out of him we did a show
about did a show about it honestly and i
was like i've been watching like bizarre
murders that true crime show and they
did a fictionalized version of it yeah
and i just saw it last night
um done by the dude that did all the
transformers with michael bay
but you wouldn't know it was a michael
bay movie it's
surprisingly light on explosions light
on exposure
good
good character building good humor in it
it had a [ __ ] great feel to that
movie
and true to south florida
it captured the feeling of this place
it's a good movie
uh john smith says don't like chick
flicks i raise you fried green tomatoes
and steel magnolias okay i'll give you
those
uh those those both of those movies are
actually pretty awesome and not gonna
lie
i did cry at the end of steel magnolias
when when she died so taylor said she
ran she's gonna see it okay go ahead and
see that um and then she asked t last uh
did i see pieces of april i did um but
it's been like a long time since i've
seen it so i'd have to like re-watch it
kayla asks um does anyone like the
awesome movie the thing from 1982
yes what are you talking about everybody
show on it everybody one of my favorite
movies i mean honestly if i'm
whatever day it is it's definitely in
the top three yeah um my top three
horror movies
you know kind of changes from day to day
it's gonna be the thing it's gonna be
the shining and it's gonna be the
haunting from 1963. yeah and
those three kind of like
you know vy for the top spot on whatever
my mood is that day but i mean the thing
i have seen it
so
many times my dad took me to see it so
my dad took me to see that three times
in the theater that [ __ ] [ __ ] had me
riveted [ __ ] scared me
all right i love it though that
solidified crustal in my mind as a
legend that one
that one had an escape from me that one
escaped from new york sure oh but
[ __ ] no man the [ __ ] dang
whoo
and you know the 2011 the thing which is
the prequel is also very it's actually
pretty good real good
the problem with the thing 2011 is that
the guys that wanted to make it
wanted wanted it to be a thing homage
and they wanted all practical effects
and evidently they came out looking
really good
but then
the studio that wanted to market it said
well it looks kind of old-fashioned we
want to cover all these practical
effects with cgi
which totally ruined the practical
effects
the cgi looks okay but man it would have
been a lot better if it was the
practical effects because honestly um
people nowadays that are in their 20s
still talk about the original thing
which is practical effects yeah and i
think i said this in one of my reviews
that i did i don't think it's gone up
yet but
the problem with a lot of movies that
came out like during the dawn of cgi
where everybody's all excited about cgi
and it's like oh my god we can like make
entire like we can render entire
monsters in cgi
which probably looked cool
in the 90s when it came out but you
watch it nowadays and it looks like ass
yeah
whereas if you see something from the
early 80s that they actually made
practically like as a puppet or whatever
it looks way better yeah see here it
doesn't age
there are there's a certain amount of
people that are very unsophisticated
when they go to see these damn movies
they want realism
you don't really want realism reality
doesn't look that good you want a
theater
and the original thing was very
theatrical it got its message across to
you it didn't need realism
i mean there's a lot of [ __ ] in there if
you really pay attention it doesn't make
any goddamn sense all the blood is green
and it's because they're trying to get a
damn rating instead of x rating and they
couldn't show blood all the time so they
would do green stuff but you don't
really notice it's alien blood anyway
yeah so you buy it you see you're buying
into it um
some you know
yeah you have certain generations of the
day they're totally immune to imagery
you can show them any kind of image
they don't really have a reaction to it
because they grew up with these little
tablets and phones in their hands they
see imagery all day long
that wasn't the situation back in the
80s you only saw a really good imagery
in the movie theaters you didn't really
see it on tv the resolution was real low
and it looked at all looked kind of fake
so you had to build up a story based
upon characters and suspense and music
and it was theater
it's theater it's not realism
and
thing part one or that first thing from
the [ __ ] 80s today actually that's
the second thing
uh they had it had that
it was because it was an alien that was
believable
i was like man something like that could
really exist it was nothing like a human
being
more like a [ __ ] amoeba and a virus
mixed in together
which is plausible
if there's an alien creature that kicks
ass and has [ __ ] existed in space
forever it would be biologically
superior to everything
that it could just grab something absorb
it and learn from it and become that
they rip they rip that idea off i
believe from h.p lovecraft's version of
the shag off
which was was one of the slave races to
the old ones
and it eventually got a hold of a brain
and became a damn super big and
overthrew the old ones
that description is kind of what you see
with the thing
it's just a [ __ ] frightening concept
an amoeba that can mimic anything
which like i said if that landed on the
planet would you we would be
be [ __ ] there'd be no way to stop it
we'd be [ __ ] and it was just scariest
monster for sure yeah by a long by a
long shot there'd be no way to stop it
nope it would be the pinnacle of bile
of evolutionary biology you could not
evolve into anything better than that
it could just mimic anything that it
conta that it comes in contact with
so it can survive anywhere
if he got a hold of a brain it would not
only have that intelligence it would
have all that knowledge
and it would just do that over and over
and over again from one world to the
next it would become the supreme being
it's just frightening
frightening concept
now
the xenomorph from alien was pretty good
but you could fight that
you couldn't fight the thing
and i think
part of the part of the inspiration came
from the blob the blob was kind of like
that but it didn't learn from you it
just absorbed you and got bigger it was
just a mindless amoeba
this was more like hp lovecraft's shag
off it's more like that
if it got a hold of your head it would
could become you
which seriously the world doesn't need
one more of me that's for sure it would
know everything that you knew
you would know everything that you would
knew and could mimic you and [ __ ] and
oh man no
that'd be a badass monster that's what
i'm saying i honestly can't think of
like a more peak uh scarier monster than
that no you can't fight it because you
don't know what it looks like
you know what i mean because it can
adapt to anything and it would know
everything sure
and it yeah it would have all the
knowledge so like i said you would not
be able to fight that couldn't find it
if if that came to earth and was
unleashed like that it'd be over yeah
every we'd be hosed
it would have the highest iq that it
came in contact with so it would very
quickly have 145 iq
and then it would just start swallowing
up educated people and would know
everything that they would know
and it would work its way up the food
chain
and it would it would get big
so it wouldn't be one thing it would be
thousands of things walking around
it would be a whole rock concerts whole
countries whole nations of [ __ ]
things coming after you you and they're
all uncut and they're all in
communication with each other like
through wi-fi somehow
nah they'd be unstoppable
no way to defeat it
in second place would be the creatures
from slither they were close to that
real similar that'd be hard to stop too
yeah
yeah
tila says is clueless a chick flick if
so i like that one
is it
um
that's the thing i kind of feel like
people
maybe sometimes use chick flick as just
kind of like a broad umbrella term for
any movie that has like women as the
main protagonist
but
that well yeah that that's a little
problematic i kind of feel like when i
say chick flick i usually mean
either like a rom-com situation or
a movie that is completely
um themed around a romantic relationship
that usually has some kind of like happy
ending like oh they got married at the
end or something like that that's what
i'm talking about it's so
clueless i don't think i would
necessarily call that a chick flick um
but clueless is awesome i just kind of
feel like i would call that a comedy
but i don't know i could be wrong about
that i haven't seen it in a while but i
do remember
john smith asked
if you're copied by the thing do you
know you're a thing
uh crustal asked that same question in
the um bonus [ __ ] material inside the
damn blu-ray you know they didn't know
the guys making the movie weren't sure
the actors
you know what do you know you're the
thing when you're the thing
i'm gonna say yeah you do know you're
the thing when you're the thing because
the thing showed um the ability to plan
and foresight so it knew that it was the
thing
the thing is is that you might be the
character
that you are in other words like if i
get absorbed tom ross is not really the
thing the thing is now pretending to be
tom ross i'm the camouflage
so the tom ross character may not know
but the overlord
thing overlord inside of me would know
but i would think yeah i would think
that you know
they seemed to i mean the way they
behaved in the movie yeah yeah i mean
they seem to have like their own goals
for [ __ ] so they did seem to be like
self-aware in that sense the tom ross
kept thing tom ross character would just
have been a camouflage it just would
have been an act
but it would be it would be able to
mimic you perfectly because it would
have all your knowledge and all your
traits so it would be a perfect
representation of me
other than the things that weren't
biological you could be a thing right
now it could be a thing but the thing is
is that it wouldn't have fillings or it
wouldn't have any kind of implants no
metal screws in it or anything because
they found out later on the second one
is that yeah the copy is only biological
there's nothing
in or inorganic in it yeah so if you had
anything inorganic implanted in you it
wouldn't be carried over
like a metal hit person here right here
tila says devil wears prada is another
chick flick i love um i remember liking
that one i think i saw that in the
theater if i remember correctly uh the
main takeaway i might have also read the
book i kind of feel like i read the book
too
but maybe i don't know i've read so many
books i forgot but i might have read the
book as well
um but the main takeaway from that movie
i know this is [ __ ] up from however
long ago that i saw it
my main takeaway from that movie was
that anne hathaway was supposed to be a
size six and was also supposed to be fat
so
i was just ki i was watching that movie
going size six size six is fat now okay
so we're doing that
and i was just gonna i know that they
were like making fun of that attitude
but
the fact that everybody in the movie was
calling anne hathaway fat through the
whole movie i was just like this is very
very disturbing to me because she is
very clearly not fat by any stretch of
the imagination but yeah so that really
did uh kind of bother me and i was
actually reading an article about that
the other day like that somebody was uh
kind of talking about that era of movies
and how that was kind of a thing they
were talking about that and um
what's the other one bridget jones diary
uh which kind of had a similar kind of
thing with like a girl that wasn't
really all that fat like and
the main plot point was that everyone
called her fat so yeah so there was that
um let me see
i saw some other uh jen did you review
pans labyrinth i still haven't
um
i kind of feel like i want to do like
all these guillermo del toro movies i
just did shape of water and uh we i did
devil's backbone
and i've been wanting to do pans
labyrinth i want to do chronos as well
and actually i have that like on dvd in
here somewhere
and so that's another one that i've been
wanting to do because i kind of feel
like that's one that a lot of people
don't talk about
but i will get around to it eventually i
promise because i do really love pan's
labyrinth a lot
uh let's see yeah tila said the blood
test scene in the thing had me biting my
fingernails and toenails so gripping
yeah that's the the blood test scene oh
yeah i mean that's really one of the
best like tension building scenes in all
of cinema to be honest with you
well jenny i would have to say that the
land cable was the solution to the
product that really does seem to be
working doesn't it
yeah so we're just going to have to get
we got to get a longer cable yeah i can
just get a longer cable okay
i'll just order another cable
later tonight or tomorrow and then we'll
figure it out so
that's good i guess that solved that
problem it's making me like not being so
angry and frustrated about it uh let's
see we're talking about the woman in
black
tila says i hate movies with happy
endings i well you know it depends on
i don't like happy endings that are
unearned i don't like happy endings just
for the sake of having a happy ending
because they're like oh we don't want
audiences get bummed out about it you
know what i mean
i kind of feel like if it should have a
shitty or sad ending then it should have
a shittier sad ending don't like [ __ ]
puss out about it you know what i mean
um let's see
dammit it's snowing oh my god i wish
it's like
it's 80 something degrees down here it
got [ __ ] hot again
ah jesus christ
another thing that a.t
see another thing that was a trip about
[ __ ] um
the thing
john carpenter's the thing is that the
black characters were not cannon fodder
usually in a horror movie the black
characters were killed early 80s yeah
they got killed off pretty early [ __ ]
no man keith david you had david you had
keith david in that [ __ ] and [ __ ] he
hung out to the very very end it was
just him and crustle at the very end
not sure who's the thing
yeah
and even even um
what was what was the other black dude's
[ __ ] character named not child's
i think i think um
[ __ ] even he the other black dude hung
out for a long time
and and [ __ ]
he had he had a good character too
remember that
[ __ ] he cut he cut [ __ ] mccready
loose
he cut the [ __ ] rope man
because i didn't know i cut him loose i
i found this and remembering the [ __ ]
the tournament
[ __ ] jacket yeah that was
that was some [ __ ] wild [ __ ] and me
it like i don't know i guess about 14 or
15.
i'm buying into this you know what i
mean i'm just like
totally into this [ __ ] movies i saw
it [ __ ] like three times in the
theater
just stuck in my head
my dad took me to see that [ __ ] like
[ __ ] three weekends in a row
when i was visiting for the summer down
in mississippi
and uh my dad was like you want to see
that again i said yeah let's see it
again [ __ ] we tried we were absorbing
that [ __ ] he loved that movie
too the thing oh what was the name of
the other the other black character it
wasn't child's
child childs was keith david's character
right i don't think i thought it was
child's the other black dude's name
he was the guy who was the cook remember
and he cut mccready loose yeah yeah yeah
and um
he falls to his knees that that thing
he's going i cut him loose i found this
what if we're wrong and all that because
yeah that's like a yeah it was just
looking
yes it was the story
tk carter as nulls nals that's what it
was nals that was another good character
well he was very different from child's
they were almost kind of like opposites
because knowles was kind of like the
sensitive guy
childs was the [ __ ] alpha
[ __ ] you know
and it was just
man it's just just a classic movie just
talking about me makes you want to see
it again as junk as i am i mean that's
another movie that i never get tired of
yeah like i said it's kind of one of
those movies yeah it's that that movie
in the shining yeah like i said even
though i've seen both of those probably
like 100 200 times if you said to me
right now hey you want to watch the
thing like the original or hey you want
to watch the shining sure
sure
yeah i'll watch them just over and over
again i think that was windows that was
going but what if we're wrong man what
if then when then [ __ ] child's like
but they were wrong [ __ ] it they were
wrong
hey
it was a [ __ ] emergency situation if
we're wrong they were wrong they were
just gonna try to damn error on the side
of [ __ ] safety
well i mean you know
but the thing has to know that it's the
thing because it set mccready up
yeah
well like i said it's self-aware it's
self-aware right
yeah
so yeah it knows it's the thing
keith david's the man they live is my
favorite oh yeah oh my god i love they
live the fight scene from they live what
is it like six minutes yeah
yeah that [ __ ] alphabet
they put the damn glasses so [ __ ]
great put the damn glasses on i love
that they did that big long fight and
then he's just finally like okay i'll
put the glasses
the scene had a deeper meaning is that
is that is that
between whites and blacks they weren't
the enemies the enemy was from without
fro
from outside
okay
the enemy was from outside it was an
alien enemy he's going look look look
remember that put the glasses on because
oh okay i see it and then they both see
that the enemies was from outside
there's something to that people that's
what [ __ ] alien fleming called
spectre that's exactly what they were
talking about
wayne dalton says hey guys if you like
the movie the thing you might want to
watch the free short film by the
director of district nine ooh that's
also a great movie uh called the volume
one zygote i think you'll both like it
the problem with this
district nine is that they never did
follow up on the story with district
nine i know he made his statement but
you could have con there should have
been a sequel to that yeah but you can't
make a sequel to everything and honestly
i kind of feel like a lot of movies that
did need sequels never got one just
because
you know
i'm honestly surprised that movies get
made the way they get made nowadays much
less like another one you know what i'm
saying yeah dj madax says dude who
played windows is actually a friend of
his he was the one in the warriors that
got thrown under the train that's right
i haven't seen the warriors in so long
to see that [ __ ] again difficult
i used to have it on dvd i don't know
what happened to it i must have lost it
when i moved
um because i feel like i lost a lot of
stuff like over my moves over the years
but i'm pretty sure i used to have it on
dvd not anymore though
i think it's on um
it might be on shutter or
amazon prime though because i'm pretty
sure i just saw it the other day when i
was scrolling through yeah cheryl says
the dog scene gave me nightmares as a
kid i mean that's still
really [ __ ] up yeah
the special effects in that i i will
fight you i mean they hold it up they're
they still look really [ __ ] good they
do the job they look really good yeah um
the
oh [ __ ] what was it going to say
never mind
they talked about the thing the best
fight movie ever they lit oh they lived
yeah that was good that was good spicy
yeah
i mean it was just like so it was
hilarious yeah they just like kept going
yeah yeah
the second the second thing was a
prequel i said that um that was what
happened yeah it was the norwegian the
norwegian camp and it's also excellent
movie
excellent it was actually i wasn't
expecting it to be good but it actually
like was better than i was it was good
real good i wish they'd done practical
they did but they covered them up i know
um yeah they should have done it they
should have had two different versions
but
i'm gonna say man horror movies
practical effects always better i would
rather see a shitty looking puppet than
shitty looking cgi yeah
and well evidently no from what i heard
from what they said the practical
effects were great
well yeah i'm sure they were they were
great but it was the studio i said well
we want a more modern looking movie and
they covered them up with cg so we want
everything to look like a shitty ass
yeah
well it didn't look shitty no no he
looked good this guy looked good it
looked good but practical would have
looked better practical would have been
more in the stream of the original
but the original had really good acting
that's really what carried that movie
and another thing is is that the balls
of the movie
there weren't any female characters in
that cast
and that was unusual even for the 80s
yeah but they said no [ __ ] it this is
[ __ ] antarctica i mean usually
there's no way to throw like a token
female in there like is a love interest
or some personal titties or something
exactly but that one had zero women no
carpenter was like [ __ ] no this isn't
this is antarctica well he went the
realism and there's no women
volunteering for this [ __ ] man they're
on a weather station out in the middle
[ __ ] nowhere man we're smart we
wouldn't yeah they're not down here
and and these were all basically
ex-military guys you know that's that's
who we're there you know
got [ __ ] ex-navy and ex-army guys i
mean you guys aren't really reading
between the lines not being ex-military
maybe you don't understand it i don't
know but you look at mcgrady and mcgrady
as an army
cavalry air officer he's from the first
cav okay through the hat and [ __ ] that's
what they're talking about so he's a
vietnam veteran
okay from first air calf
and then the other guys are probably
[ __ ] like
navy communicators like windows windows
would have been a naval
radio operator also known as
communicator and then the other guys
gnaws would have been like a navy or an
air force cook
you know or maybe army cook it's hard to
say
you look at [ __ ] you look at
you look at childs and that's [ __ ]
army infantry or something you know
these are all ex-military guys
from korea and vietnam that's what
they're talking about that's the only
dudes that went to places like that
they were
ex-military contractors for the
government
and that's the way those camps would
look
and they would suck they would suck
you'd have
it was like it was when i was stationed
in [ __ ] egypt at the mfo mission
[ __ ] which is a u.n mission
enforcing that peace treaty between the
israelis and the egyptians when you
looked at their compound that's the way
south camp looked from the mfo south
camp was bigger but it's that same [ __ ]
if you were to pick part of south camp
up and put it
up in antarctica and only have [ __ ]
12 guys on it that's what it would look
like yeah they got blasteroids what was
that asteroids deluxe that's it
and they're just trying to run that damn
camp
so
no i'm [ __ ] i'm with it i'm like
that's it that was a very realistic
dj maniac says the thing is currently
free on 2b last i looked yeah as far as
i know at least i mean i was on 2b today
and the thing was on there yeah so yeah
you can watch it for free no excuse um
connor batson says by the way jenny i
heard the movie hellbender is a good one
i've been hearing a lot of good [ __ ]
about that one that was one that shutter
just put up i think last week
and i've been seeing a lot of good
buzz about that one so yeah i definitely
will probably watch that one this
weekend and maybe we can talk about it
uh like on one of the matinee shows next
week perhaps because i do actually want
to see it because i have been hearing a
lot of good about it you're in there
talking about the score from they live
[Music]
yeah like a carpenter carpenter wrote
that [ __ ] he could be a genius when it
came to [ __ ] scores it was he was hit
or miss but he when he hit when he was
hitting he was hidden he was really it
i still kind of want to watch some of
his later [ __ ] yeah but some of this
[ __ ] i don't think he had anything to do
with
well
what was the movie that he did go so
mars didn't seem like they had anything
to do well i've seen that it's not good
i wanted to see um
the ward which i think came out and i
want to say 2004 but it might be later
than that
um
i haven't really heard much one way or
the other about that i'm imagining it
sucks but i don't really know
because i kind of feel like like i love
john carpenter but it does kind of feel
like his best [ __ ] was his old [ __ ]
but you know that's okay we can't all be
look the man made [ __ ] halloween and
the thing and escape from new york and
[ __ ] jesus christ that should be more
than enough
well halloween
well i said halloween oh did you say
halloween yeah and i was just kind of
like well you know most of us will never
do that
13th part 3.
he didn't do that i didn't do that no i
thought he did that one too
not francine i mean halloween three
didn't you do that score to that um well
he met another score i don't think he
had that much to do with it i mean he
did but
i don't know how i don't remember how
involved he was with that one okay
halloween three was one of my favorite
movies because i had never seen
halloween one or two i just [ __ ]
jumped in at three was a kid and i was
like man i love this movie
well like i said i kind of damn silver
shamrock
i kind of feel like um
it was one of those movies people didn't
love it at the time we've talked about
that it's uh you know people don't
didn't love it at the time because they
were like where's michael myers i don't
get it yeah um but you know now now
everybody's kind of like oh my god it's
awesome but you know it's that kind of
thing it's it's kind of sad because i
kind of feel like john carpenter's
movies other than halloween which was
like a massive [ __ ] success at the
time that it came out
but other than that it really does seem
like most of his [ __ ] it needed some
time to like [ __ ] age you know what
i'm saying even like escape from new
york even the thing didn't really do all
that great when it was out in the
theater people were like meh or whatever
for i don't know why but
it really took like a long time for it
to
even escape from la got better as it got
a little bit older i mean even though it
was [ __ ] wacky the the the [ __ ]
i still can't sit through it the tone
wasn't quite the same still can't fit
through it yeah tone wasn't the same but
they're they're i kind of like it
it's kind of a parody
but it is all right it's okay
yeah this is okay i think maybe one of
these days a re-edit also a re-edit
probably would have been a little bit
better i think you could have gotten
that same tone
it was a little too funny
too comedic at certain points
that was the problem i had with yeah
yeah
because
okay mixing horror and comedy those two
things go very well together if
you know what you're doing
it's a very difficult balancing act yeah
um and
i kind of feel like it's it's something
that a lot of people attempt and very
very few people can pull off
successfully
uh strong 78 says cigarette burns was
solid it was indeed actually that was
probably one of my favorite masters of
horror episodes um i just really liked
the whole concept of it i mean [ __ ]
udokir was in it norman reedus was in it
it was [ __ ] great
t thought season of the witch was good i
liked that movie
i liked it
yeah i mean yeah i thought it was good
well like i said a lot of people didn't
like it at the time because it wasn't
they were expecting they were expecting
something else yeah i didn't know any
better yeah when i saw it so in some
ways
this is why i like to come at movies
with as little baggage yeah as possible
i mean it's it's kind of hard to do that
especially like in an older movie
because you're gonna have heard like
some
some [ __ ] about it one way or the other
but
if it's a newer movie i don't even
really like to read this the
summary or anything like that
that last week that last brand new
halloween that we saw
from halloween kills halloween kills
they had some silver shamrock masks in
that
when we saw that i was tripping i was
like jenny man they need to make another
one of those looking
season of the witch reboot because
they're they tried to tie them together
in that last one just a little bit and i
remember when we saw that maybe we were
like talking about the way home it's
like ooh now they should totally do a
crossover with the silver shamrock
company yeah and then the next movie
that they do
because like i said they did the
halloween rema in 2018
and then they did halloween kills
and i said well now the third one
should be like
halloween three season of the witch yeah
so it's like a new pr new trilogy yeah
so they should make that one and tie it
in with silver shamrock that's what i
would do if i was writing this [ __ ] but
i'm not obviously nobody's paying me the
big bucks but that's what i would do
because you know
uh wayne dalton says the void from 2016
has a carpenter thing vibe to it i agree
i really really did like that movie and
i've seen that like a couple of times it
has like yeah it has like a john
carpenter thing it's like a lovecraftian
thing because like i said john carpenter
was really into lovecraft and a lot of
his stuff while not overtly lovecraftian
um was in spirit
kind of lovecraftian so the void had
that as well if you so if you haven't
seen the void um and you like john
carpenter movies yeah you should totally
watch that one too because that's really
good really good
and uh yeah season of the which would be
a good one to remake yeah i kind of feel
like they could do a lot with that
concept it's a ridiculous concept but
that's okay i said that they should have
remade that years ago
i mean on the show i was like dad this
movie is right for that
yeah
i mean we've talked about that like i
said i'm not averse to remakes
in as a concept
i just wish that they would take movies
that
were good ideas but weren't um you know
didn't like live up to their full
potential
at the time at the time for whatever
reason because they didn't have the
money or whatever
and i wish they would remake that
i just i think like
the the problem people have with remakes
is that people keep remaking like good
movies dmitri is asking for going to
mannequins tonight i said tomorrow maybe
yeah i don't know if i want to get her
tonight wait wait dimitri showed up oh
yeah dimitri's asking oh i thought he
showed up in the chat
i was like i don't know man because we
did it tomorrow maybe we did it last
yeah we did it last friday you know
there's a lot of people there
yeah and it was fun but it's like i
wasn't really having a good time when i
first got there because i was already
kind of drunk it's 7 30 i mean it's
still early but [ __ ]
if i'm gonna go out i like to have a
while to like get ready and like just
relax ahead of time i don't really like
being rushed yeah and i kind of feel
like you know when i do the show i want
to just hang out with you know i just
want to drink and hang out with people
on the show i don't want to like have to
think about oh [ __ ] now i have to like
get ready to go out yeah you know what i
mean i'm already kind of like inebriated
so you know
uh jenny did i see the autopsy of jane
doe says tila yes i did i've seen it a
couple of times and it's awesome
um
and again that just goes to show you
don't need an elaborate
setup you don't need elaborate anything
i mean that movie pretty much takes
place entirely in one room
and it's fan [ __ ] tastic that's a
really really good movie
cheryl says i didn't love the witch
there i said it
i get it it's um
most people did love the witch but if
you didn't love it i mean i loved it but
if you didn't i guess the season of the
wishes no uh the witch from the robert
eggers movie same guy that did uh the
lighthouse
you see it yeah i don't think you've
seen it um i've seen it a couple times
and i i really really liked it but i get
it like if you don't it's
it's one of those ones that
and i'm all for this
but i know that some people are not
liking this whole trend that they call
what do they call it elevated horror
um what's that
meaning uh horror that has like a lot of
deeper meaning a lot of it's got like
kind of like slow burn or it's kind of
more like metaphorical
uh or more psychological horror and a
lot of people don't really like that
um because they think oh it's boring i
just want like monsters rampaging or
whatever which is fine i like that too
but
honestly like the witch was like pretty
[ __ ] awesome i thought it was like
pretty creepy but if you don't like it
like i i get it i do get it
uh but autopsy of jane doe yeah if you
haven't seen that
as i said that's one of the best
examples of
one location i guess what they would
call a bottle movie
of one location horror and it's like
super super creepy because like the
whole time i was just like raven like
what the [ __ ] is going on with this
[ __ ] body you know what i mean and it
was just
yeah it's really good it's really good
if you haven't seen it i don't want to
spoil it but it's really good in recent
time my favorite horror would have been
vivarium
god damn that was so good yeah god
didn't like it i always [ __ ] loved it
i just i love anything with that like
weird uncanny like twilight zone kind of
i love the twilight zone vibe of that
yeah you get abducted by some [ __ ]
extra dimensional
creature that makes you raise its baby
that's some weird [ __ ] there
in a in a fake suburbia
that there's no escape from that's
probably one of my favorite hor it's
it's like is that a horror movie yeah i
guess it's a horror movie yeah it's
psychological horror all right
but
i mean yeah i was i was really into that
and um i'm trying to think of like what
my favorite
one of these days i'll probably have to
make like a list of my favorite horror
movies of like the last 10 years or the
last 20 years or something like that one
that's come up like everybody knows i
love hereditary i love that movie a lot
um another one that i'm supe that i was
super super into i think did i review it
i can't remember
was uh the invitation
if you guys haven't seen the invitation
um
that one was also
fantastic that was a movie very
psychological horror i'm not gonna i
don't want to spoil anything about it
like where it goes because it's way way
better
if you don't know what's coming
um but that was one of the that movie i
was just like on the [ __ ] edge of my
seat the whole entire time that was one
of the tensest movies that i ever sat
through then you're talking about
vavarium now i'm saying it's a good one
yeah bavaria was [ __ ] weird
it was up there with con i don't
almost like like the thing kind of
situation
but very different in a way well how do
you describe that [ __ ]
but see i love movies like that imagine
if the predator was a rapist
you take care of its baby
that's some weird [ __ ]
and you couldn't get away from it
i mean i loved everything about that
movie i loved the whole aesthetic vibe
like i said it came across like at first
it's very much like a twilight zone
episode
but that's what i like that that's not a
knock against it because i love the
twilight zone i love that whole vibe i
had one dude say well yeah it's it's
it's a
it's a um what do you call it he says
it's a uh
it's symbolic for raising a child it
says no there's no symbolism involved it
made you raise its child yeah but simple
doesn't matter no it's not so it's not
symbolism that's not the right word yeah
um
it's not so much symbolism it's it's
analogous it wasn't even an announcement
to raising a child like a human child
but it's like uh but it's uh an
exaggeration of that it wasn't even an
analogy it made you raise its child it
wasn't an analogy it made you do it
it just it but the child that was making
you raise was a counterfeit human
yeah because that's what it had to look
like in order to [ __ ]
to complete its life cycle so it wasn't
it wasn't a in a now it wasn't an
analogy that's what it was
it made you do that it made you raise it
like it was a human yeah but
so it could impersonate a human what
that person meant
and i got this from the movie as well
was that yes this is an a symbiotic
alien
life form that's making like literally
yeah that's making you raise its
offspring like a cuckoo bird like a
cuckoo bird which you know they did kind
of like bring that and that analogy into
it but they're also making uh
again making an analogy to
raising a human baby yeah and you like
aging and dying and [ __ ] like that so
they so they it was like a parallel kind
of but it is the thing is though it
wasn't symbolic in that way
well like i said symbolic that's not the
right analogy yeah that's making you
raise its baby and if you were raising
it like a human
it was forcing you to raise it like a
human and yeah it accelerated your life
cycle
it because it was feeding off of you
yeah remember how like a human child
does that to you yeah but it was and it
was an alien child yeah it teaches you
before your time yeah
that was the thing that [ __ ] blew my
mind is that
it got bigger
so it grew
and it grew quickly in a relatively
small period of time
the parents were being fed
it did eat some stuff
but why did they die they could have
only died because it was eating them
like a parasite
remember that yeah and then he's digging
to try to get out because that was his
only way and it kind of symbolized work
yeah in a certain way well and work that
was like not productive not very
productive sure right
and it was almost like analogous to like
a factory job yeah like you working your
whole life and like not getting anywhere
because of it right but that's that but
but the thing is you could read a lot of
stuff into that [ __ ] in a way you didn't
have to but you didn't have but in a way
that's a great
reproduction
of of human life to help this alien
child to be more realistic
in his lifestyle yeah
it was a
it was a false human child that's
[ __ ] weird well it's a great idea and
that was irish [ __ ] that's some irish
people that came out it was a little bit
of a weird [ __ ] i want to say too it was
a little bit of an i don't want to say
indictment that's kind of too strong a
word but i think it was like a little
bit of an indictment of
the kind of uh idealized family liberty
yeah we're going to live like in a
suburban life we're going to raise a
baby everything's going to be this and
that so it was kind of like making fun
of that as well a little bit so there
was a little bit of that too well it was
just it was a creature that wanted
that lifestyle and that upbringing for
its offspring so it could be a fake
human but it was all accelerated and
condensed into a small
portion of time which made it seem more
brutal
but it still got the job done it
consumed both of those human beings and
it made a child
that that could pass itself off as a
human
to continue its life cycle in some other
dimension
it was definitely in another dimension
it pulled the damn curb up and ran
underneath it yeah and they were falling
through other dimensions there was more
of them well they were going in other
houses yeah other houses same shape
there were more of them kind of like a
damn wasp nest yeah and they were all
together but in different dimensions
like goddamn that would be so good we've
seen it like so we saw it two or three
times in the theater and then we bought
it and we've watched it a couple times
since
and i like it better right so this thing
is like like a parasite kind of like a
wasp where it's [ __ ] grabbing spiders
and putting eggs in them you know what i
mean getting them in the net it's kind
of like that
but it's another dimension and then you
and then it better begs to ask well how
long has this been going on with
probably [ __ ] tens of millions of
years yeah you know evidently evolved
alongside of us it's not [ __ ] from
another planet it's from another
dimension and it's always been here
that's some bizarre [ __ ] there so i'm
like going yeah that
that's another good alien
not only was the thing a good
representation of an alien and maybe the
xenomorph but that thing from vivarium i
mean that's actually more i love the
concept
and i love the aesthetic of that movie
it's just kind of like
we've seen it like probably five or six
times at this point and it never gets
old i always find like new [ __ ] it's a
creature in a slightly higher dimension
that can look down on you and do all
this weird i mean it's so great and put
you in a damn nest with a dozen other
human beings and then they raise my baby
basically yeah and then they go out and
do that [ __ ] my baby that just goes
yeah yeah like screams
pretends to be a person
and then when you look in the book and
look at the static on the television or
really what it is
you're caught in a big pattern it's not
physical whatever it is
the kid was just a manifestation of that
to be honest though like when i was
watching that movie because like i said
i don't have any kids in my own and i
never had any desire to so when i saw
the kid in that i was just kind of like
so like a regular kid then
i was just kind of like that's like what
every kid seems like to me so it's not
all that weird that's like not alien
stardog778 says i hate the term elevated
horror i kind of do too
um not really sure who coined that
but
yeah there's a lot of uh that's a very
loaded term
i get what they're
saying but elevated horror
implies
that horror as a genre is something that
is not
uh
worthy of
attention or worthy of
i mean and i kind of feel like it's
better nowadays than it used to be
because look i grew up in the 80s
and people talked about horror like it
was um
you know that's like something only
stupid teenage boys watched even though
i was really into it too
and
that's really like unfair because horror
to me
to me i kind of feel like it's the best
genre they can do
because you can explore a lot of stuff
within that framework
and i kind of feel like just saying that
it's oh it's just slasher movies or it's
just these kind of like b movies or
whatever somebody asks if there's family
horror yeah there is be goosebumps
goosebumps would be family or wait
gremlins would be funny what are we
talking about like fame like horror that
family
like the whole family can watch like
kids and stuff is that what we're
talking about yeah i think that's what
he's talking about
i mean i'm not sure or are you talking
about like horror as between between
family rappers
because i don't know i can think of that
stuff too but yeah so so that does kind
of bother me because i feel like
like i said it's better than it used to
be but i do kind of feel like there was
always a stigma
about horror as a genre like it was
somehow
not serious or you know it was just like
pulpy or that was something that like
teenagers liked but you grew out of it
and
i think that's really [ __ ] up because
honestly
horror
is such a wide
umbrella you can explore a lot of [ __ ]
and horror that you can't really
uh you know explore in other genres
maybe and the thing about horror is that
you can like cross breed it with lots of
other genres too and you know horror
fans will still watch it
um because we're generally a pretty
open-minded lot i'll watch pretty much
anything uh you know as long as it has
some kind of like horror element to it i
don't really care like what genre it is
but yeah so i mean i i get what they're
saying
that it's sort of like
the term elevated horror i guess they're
just kind of saying oh we're going back
to the you know the old days where it's
more of like a slow burn but they're
just trying to like distinguish it from
b movie monster movie slasher horror
because i do kind of feel like some
people maybe
still have the misconception
that when you say horror you're talking
about like gory stuff or like slasher
movies or something like that which is
absolutely not the case
so they're just trying to like
distinguish it probably not the best
term uh because it sounds a little
uh pretentious or a little judgy you
know what i'm saying but
what are you gonna do that's the term
somebody came up with i don't love it
either gonna say
uh tammy asked if anyone had seen snow
piercer yes we've seen snow piercer i've
seen snow piercer uh and yes it was very
good cheryl says i just got gretel and
hansel anyone seen it we saw it in the
theater i didn't love it
um
but it was okay tom really did not like
it he thought that the whole thing
should have been about the witch
and that the hansel and gretel
characters were kind of boring and like
it shouldn't have been focused on them
which i kind of get that i mean it
probably would have been better if it
was more because the witch was [ __ ]
awesome but you know what i mean
uh let's see uh cheryl says the
invitation is really good honestly
i just rewatched that movie again
um
like probably a month or two ago and i
liked it just as much second even though
i knew it was coming although i will say
if you haven't seen the invitation
it's better going into it not knowing
what's going to happen
you know what i mean because i watched
it i think it came out in 2016.
i watched it really not having any idea
what was gonna
what direction it was gonna go
and
the whole time i was like on the edge
it's going oh my god what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen and like then when it did
happen i was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it
was like yeah so you don't really like
expect how it's gonna go but that's one
of my favorite uh horror movies from the
last few years for sure
really really good
i kind of otzlan my buddy down tijuana
says bavarium is a good movie and the
director lorcan finnegan has not made
another one
i thought he hadn't and that's like
really a shame yeah
i'm gonna call him i'm gonna tell him to
make another one you're gonna call him
yeah
make another movie yeah the variable was
so [ __ ] good are you out there are
you watching this it was a good movie
yeah that was a honestly
and it's like hilarious because we saw
that in the theater and we didn't really
know because like i said we were doing
the matinee at the time and we were just
kind of like going and seeing everything
we were just going and seeing three
movies a week even like shitty ones
and
i didn't really know what to expect with
that and i ended up like really really
loving it and i i thought that you
probably wouldn't like it but i loved it
yeah so you surprised me with that and
uh i surprised jenny on on [ __ ]
artists up the fence too i really
thought you would hate that that's when
i got into the jet pack
it's people like you like jesse
eisenberg no [ __ ] that dude actually
when he gets involved in his little
projects he gets involved in some really
good movies eisenberg all right i
respect his
i respect his judgment about what kind
of project to get involved in
if you haven't seen art of self-defense
it's a great movie okay
this thing is coming from
the most soy [ __ ] this [ __ ]
who wrote this movie just soy as [ __ ]
all right
he's afraid of masculinity
and he's afraid of warrior masculinity
he starts starts to talk about
a [ __ ] karate dojo
and here's the thing coming out of the
military [ __ ] you know what i mean i
was in real good infantry units
first in the 506 first 327 first 327
recon he starts talking about
what a warrior cult is
and even though this movie is [ __ ]
bizarre and funny it is absolutely
accurate he called it that's what it is
and yeah he tries he i don't think he
tries
he does have kind of a cynical view on
it
but it's still accurate it's accurate
that's that's what it is so he kind of
accurately called
called it about what a warrior cult is
well sometimes people that are very
inside of it you're right yeah have a
better perspective on it than somebody
that is inside of it yeah because you
can't really see
right all the kind of like nooks and
crannies he calls it if you're inside of
what's funny is that he kind of bags on
it also kind of reinforces is it at the
same time
and
he's using karate as an analogy for what
he's talking about karate is just a
symbol for what he's talking about
but in the end the honor of karate is
saved you just got to see the movie to
understand it
and he he he's correct he's correct
about
the lessons okay i'm big into [ __ ]
philosophical and moral lessons that
things teach but for me morality or
true morality are ideas that work in
nature things that really work if it
doesn't work then it's not true
it has to be something that works
something that survives the test of
nature and time
and i gotta say this director [ __ ]
the guy that wrote this and everything
yeah he's right he's right yeah it's
funny but yeah there's a lot to learn
from it there's a lot to learn from it
and he called it i'm gonna watch that
[ __ ] tomorrow
well like i said you have to think too
that sometimes people that are
artists yeah you don't necessarily have
to experience something to understand
something what it is right yeah um and
sometimes like i said you have a better
perspective on it from the outside not
always
um but sometimes if you have particular
insight yeah you do what he's doing
is he's retelling the story
of the black dragon society
you go who the [ __ ] the [ __ ] is the
black we did a show about that yeah
[Laughter]
when i was a kid growing up we were
looking at [ __ ] dc and marvel comics
they always had a [ __ ]
ad in the back
talking about
a program that would teach you the democ
death touch
dude from the black dragon society you
know what was his i would so abuse that
if i was it was this white dude with a
fro
that he [ __ ] what was that guy's name
who from the black dragon yeah from the
black dragon uh doc did start with the d
i'll remember it in a second oh yeah
yeah i don't have no draco draco
no that's harry potter
[Laughter]
it was this
it was this [ __ ] okay i'm gonna look
it up right now it was this martial
artist and he really was a martial
artist but the [ __ ] was crazy
okay
um
and and that's what the st the story is
not directly about him but that's what
they're talking about they're talking
about it in slightly different forms
we're trying to remember that dude's
name is
javi and melinda says jesse eisenberg is
a cool dude my father saw him on the
street in manhattan and said hello
you're from the movies and my dad said
he was mad cool and friendly yeah and
chatted for his dad
yeah i mean everything i've heard i
don't think i've ever heard anything bad
about him although you know it's not
like i go looking for [ __ ] but
he always does seem cool and he's always
good in like all the movies you should
probably still like i said you should
see the social network you would
probably like that where he plays uh
zuckerberg he plays like the founder of
facebook so he was good in that as well
i think i saw that in the theater also
now that i'm thinking about it that was
a while back count dante there you go
kevin dante
count dante was the name of the dude
let me show you count dante
cheryl says we should do a watch party
in the sense that like we watch
something
with everybody and like then we
commented on it in real time
we should probably do that i should
maybe figure out how to do that one of
these days because to be fair
sometimes at night like sometimes after
the shows like we'll watch something
because i was like well let's just watch
something that i don't really have to
think about like something we've seen
before or something that's like shitty
or whatever like a yeah i'll usually
watch like a rooftrax episode or
something
and uh
when we do that
sometimes we make some really really
funny [ __ ] comments i mean i'm just
saying like from our point of view it's
like it's really funny and i was just
kind of like every now and then i feel
like maybe
man we should like
have had this live stream because it's
like sad that it's like wasted
cause we said some funny [ __ ] that's the
dude i'm talking about count dante from
the black dragon society the deadliest
man alive you can buy his training
manuals to the back of the comic book
he's the deadliest man yeah but
but that was a real man
and he really did getting a lot of
[ __ ] trouble with martial arts he was
in the she was he had a dojo in chicago
and he had a bunch of dudes that were
kind of like black panthers that [ __ ]
uh trained underneath him he was the
only dude that would [ __ ] train like
black panther type dudes he's a white
guy but he had a big afro and [ __ ]
all kinds of [ __ ] went down with the
[ __ ] police department he blew up
another dojo he was it was called the
dojo wars of the chicago dojo wars
blew up another dojo
uh
[ __ ] attacked another dojo one of his
students [ __ ] stabbed another dude
with a sword and killed him and you all
thought cobra kai was
created fiction no that [ __ ] really
happened from the chicago dojo wars it
was cal dante
okay karate dojo is fighting yeah it
sounds ridiculous yeah and he was a
hairdresser
he was a hairdresser and he would write
these books about he was a man of
creation and destruction that he could
create beautiful hair and he could [ __ ]
you up with his hands it it it's a wild
story okay
and it was all true okay sorry i was
thinking of that eddie the art but the
movie [ __ ] art of self-defense is
about a situation like that
but it's deeper and it's
it's a lot more instructive there's a
lot more [ __ ] lessons to learn about
violence and how violence can come back
on you and how to train a [ __ ]
to be a badass and how to take things
from people to make them meaner and how
to change people and then where did
these bad [ __ ] come from
what were they like before they were bad
[ __ ] the cycle of bad
[ __ ] that that but it's it's a
great movie and
um the dude who directed that with jesse
and jesse eisenberg they called it
that's exactly what it is that's it well
that's why it was funny to me jenny was
like he's not gonna like this movie i'm
sitting there and just
absorbing it and learning well because
when i got dead i was like that's
amazing
you have a thing that's a masterpiece
that any time anyone is quote unquote
soy in a movie which i hate that
terminology
i can't believe that i had to say that
out loud as [ __ ] but um
anytime somebody's like that he's
usually like oh my god
and he gets all like upset about it
so
no it is and so when we were watching
that movie i was just kind of like oh
jesus christ it's like i was thinking it
was funny but like the whole time i was
thinking i couldn't really enjoy it
because i thought he was like hating it
but then so i was surprised at the end
that he actually like really dug it
tila says yeah they wanna they're trying
to set up a watch party for us to do
everybody wants to watch a movie with us
together we'll all watch movies like a
watch party well yeah we can tell we got
well we have this
land cable going so that will help
and uh yeah we can watch i mean like i
said we can just watch one on this end
and then uh you know everybody can watch
the same one as us right i don't know
what one you guys are gonna pick though
i mean is it gonna be something it's
probably better to be something like
kind of bad but fun
you know
those are like the most fun ones i think
yeah cheryl says hi pookie yeah she just
like came and
went over here and like
licked my fingers and then she was like
okay i'm off over here now eating her
wet food
murder hornet says that i'm an expert in
the dim mock the dim mock was the death
touch
and that [ __ ]
where you could just chat you hit
somebody and they don't die right away
they might die a week or two later
uh
of course that gives you a lot of leeway
[Laughter]
dude could die to car accident because
yeah it's because i [ __ ] hit him yeah
i did five weeks ago thank you yeah
did that [ __ ] five weeks ago
what a badass i am yeah that's like some
[ __ ] but uh yeah that's two movies
for you
that if you guys haven't seen it i know
we got some people that [ __ ] give way
to to to to uh
to our recommendations you want to see
bavarium
and you want to see
art of self-defense
they both have eisenberg in it but
they're both different directors
they're both masterpieces and they came
out in the same year if i remember
correct i was blown away
well yeah it was the same year or like
maybe a year apart i can't remember
right i was blown away i love those
movies kind of athlon brings up a sheet
of kim the shitty kim [ __ ] kim's another
[ __ ]
the thing is though that's one of my
favorite things ever his him like
sneaking around outside of like a modest
suburban home pretending to be a ninja
yeah that's a big difference between a
shitty hilarious is she the cute that's
one of the funniest things all right
do you guys don't know what is she the
kim ishita kim
was a comic book ninja he would sell
ninja training manuals up in the back of
the comic books
and uh
he also
he would sell vhs tapes back in the 80s
and then there they are on youtube you
can find them oh yeah copy to put them
on they're the most ridiculous things
ever they're things that would never
ever [ __ ] help you at all they're
priceless
seriously they would just never help you
and he's a [ __ ]
long-haired haired dweeby
white dude in a [ __ ] fake ninja
outfit
trying to he's larping he's [ __ ]
live-action role-playing as a ninja
it's something that maybe a 13-year-old
boy might be impressed with but no
there's nothing there you know what i
mean he's [ __ ] creeping underneath
the windows back and forth
there's no sneaking
okay back in the 80s i kind of feel like
well i'm going to like take a bunch of
money from 13 year olds and advertising
in comic books although
i will say i think he actually did
believe this yeah i think he believed it
i think he believed he believed his own
[ __ ] he seemed to he's here right
and but there's a big difference between
say
cal dante and the sheet of kim ishita
kim believed his own [ __ ] but a
sheet of kim weighed 125 pounds to get
his ass beat okay i could be he would
get his ass come on beat
all right even back in the 80s right
count
i would have been right by all [ __ ]
witness by all [ __ ] accounts though
count dante could fight
and he got kicked off of movie sets
uh [ __ ] because they had him on movie
sets in exchange for [ __ ] bruce lee
and he wouldn't pull punches he'd
[ __ ] hurt you
okay on camera so they had to get rid of
his he was a lunatic
count dante was a lunatic
uh but he could fight and he could train
other people to fight it was full
contact martial arts
kung fu type stuff
kind of like prototype
very much prototype ultimate fighting
all right
and uh he was basically kind of like a
gang leader ended up in chicago
if you disrespected his dojo he'd come
and put a bomb outside your [ __ ] dojo
trying to blow it up he took that [ __ ]
seriously
yeah
but it was it's funny when you think
about it it is very it's very funny when
you think about it because
what you're talking about is cobra kai
well like i said exactly what you're
talking about sometimes like i love
cobra kai okay like we watch like all
seasons of it and sometimes you watch it
you're like this isn't all that
believable but then
i think about
all that countdown yeah and i'm like
okay
yeah this is actually beautiful people
aren't really that stupid yeah
they will fight over the stupidest [ __ ]
imagine live action role players
larpers that were larping about being
kung fu masters
but they actually didn't know
they actually would fight and actually
were pretty good at fighting
within within the [ __ ] within the
[ __ ] confines of kung fu i guess you
could say
and they would hurt you and [ __ ] set
bombs and [ __ ] sent students to come
stab you
okay but you did still deal with larpers
but they're doing it for real and that's
what count dante was well i mean you
know nobody and he was a hairdresser
can't trust nobody just saying that he
was a hairdresser can't trust nobody
with a big old afro
yeah
which
there are some duck there's some um
what do you call it uh
[Music]
interviews with some of his students
that were still floating around on
youtube just five six years ago
and uh they had a couple of black guys
that were his students and they said
that he was [ __ ] great they liked him
um that he was in those days up in
chicago
he was really one of the only dojos that
would take a black students
yeah
there was like a whole yeah so he was
kind of in a way in an innovator in that
way that um
that if you were black and you wanted to
[ __ ] learn martial arts you had to
kind of go to count
dante that he would because they were
real
stringent about who they would train
because this is like
the the the selling point was is that
this is some deadly secret [ __ ]
that only the chinese knew about
that's just why nowadays what are you
talking about white people really [ __ ]
nobody wants you to do this
yeah oh everybody's going to click on
that yeah oh somebody doesn't want me to
know that look no but if really nobody
wants you to know that it wouldn't be on
the internet as an ad just a pro tip not
only were white people not supposed to
know definitely black people weren't
supposed to know about it that was the
[ __ ] selling point back then
but
but uh no he had black students and
[ __ ] they said he they said that his
his dojo was great they did full contact
[ __ ] fighting and
worked out and beat the [ __ ] out of each
other and fight
and uh
you know we're proud to be in there
uh but look
let me nip this [ __ ] in the bud
is kung fu better than mma no [ __ ]
mixed martial arts and [ __ ] these
guys that do [ __ ] now they would [ __ ]
those dudes up
okay because you
because mma is really what bruce lee was
envisioning
okay back a long time ago a style
without a style a style that just worked
that it didn't it wasn't within the
confines of say kung fu or
karate or it was just a fighting style
that actually worked well that's mma
that's mma
and when i was a kid something like mma
would have been you would think that
it'd be criminal or illegal to do that
you know we didn't realize that no you
could go into free form fighting
you know you could do it but it would
have seemed mma
if you were to [ __ ] take take me back
grandparents will tell you too man
because we grew up together
[ __ ] if you take me back to like 1986
or something or 85 and [ __ ] explain
mma
what what mma was i would think that
something like that would be illegal
because we only knew boxing and maybe
some you know what i mean
[ __ ]
we got taekwondo karate
that's something like mma that might be
[ __ ] illegal then it'll kill you and
that's where these movies like
bloodsport came from
we're fighting without any rules
but there were rules you know what i
mean just there were rules it's just
that they weren't within them
they weren't rules with yeah don't worry
about it
maybe i'm just going on too long about
it
it was just
it was just another time
mma would have seemed to be kind of
illegal back in those days oh i can't do
i remember when [ __ ] ultimate
fighting came out cage fighting people
were appalled
they were appalled by that [ __ ] that
ended up becoming mma
and sometimes everybody's just kind of
like yeah okay you're right
but ultimate fighting i think some guys
actually got killed in ultimate fighting
but people got killed in boxing it's
just they don't really put they don't
really i mean honestly um if you go into
it knowing that that is a possibility
um
it's a sport like any other yeah i don't
really christopher reeves got killed
[ __ ] jumping his horse okay
in the english equestrian english jumper
[ __ ] arena
i didn't even get killed i mean if
you're paralyzed i mean if you're an
adult and you know that that is a
possibility and you are cognizant that
that might happen to you
then i don't really have a problem with
it to be honest it's your choice so
uh so yeah they're talking about
everybody really seems to want us to do
like some watch party [ __ ]
which like i said i've been thinking
about that for a while so maybe we
should and tila says all drinkers in the
chat must line up their drink of choice
for movie night yeah we could even do
like themes it'd be super fun
um we could pick some movies uh put it
to a vote
tila is recommending ed wood
we can't put the movie on the screen
well no no we don't do that like we
could watch it like i could put it on
that computer or something like we could
watch it like over there because we get
a [ __ ] strike
right i mean if everybody else was
watching it at the same time yeah we
don't have to have it on the screen
right that's all yeah
because yeah you don't want to get to
monetize but we could just be like
watching it in another window or i could
put it on on that computer right there
and we could watch it and everybody else
could be watching it also so we could
kind of all be watching at the same time
and uh yeah that might work out
i mean
god damn i love the lost bastard every
time
brings that up that was like i don't
think i have that on blu-ray do i uh no
i'm pretty sure it's still on tubie uh
you can watch that yeah cheryl says
something like flesh for frankenstein
for the watch party or i'm sure tom
would have some ideas but jenny's taste
is top notch oh thank you
um yeah i could probably come up with
something
honestly it might be good to see
something that i that we haven't seen
before so we can like react to it in
real time now ts wasn't petey wheat
straw doing kung fu back in the day yeah
he was oh yeah in the 70s everybody was
into this kung fu was just like some new
[ __ ] and you're like oh wow
i guess if you learn that you can kick
anybody's ass as it was like buying a
gun
so it was it was white dudes and black
dudes very much into this like well this
kung fu thing they'll come from china or
whatever if you know that then you're
almost like invincible so they just kind
of took that and ran with it in the
movies so petey wheat straw
well
i don't know if that was that in petey
wheat straw was that that was we just
watched okay we watched um petey weeds
draw the devil son-in-law yeah that was
good
um i don't know if kung fu was in that
one a little bit though it was most of
it was most of his [ __ ] had was in the
other movie that he did [ __ ] uh
uh
what was his name what was the movie
comes out of prison it becomes a [ __ ]
pimp and he's the secretary uh yeah yeah
i think that's where he mostly did the
did the uh kung fu double mate dolomite
yeah dolomite told me
great movie
the exploitation
black product
it was just you know it was kind of like
white lightning and gator you know what
i mean it was white product it was the
same [ __ ] red deck redneck
well you're just making things for a
specific audience you know yeah that's
all it is you're giving people what they
wanted to see sure
sure
murder hornet return says i took shrooms
hours ago i'm surprised they're still
hitting me yeah yeah he's tripping on
shrooms yeah do we look weird right now
yeah that's right yeah comes in kung fu
is in dolomite yeah
because because dolomite was a was again
a secret agent and a pip so he has to
know kung fu
and he was and he also had a [ __ ] um
sub machine gun kind of like a
california version of an uzi africa like
a backup you know yeah yeah
well i do kind of feel like well after
i mean bruce lee movies
were massively massively popular yeah um
so i kind of feel like in the 1970s
after everybody saw bruce lee movies
every like exploitation movie after that
had to have kung fu in it yeah because
that was just what you did
it didn't even matter if the movie's
about kung fu or not you had to put like
some [ __ ] kung fu in there because
that's just like [ __ ] what it is now
dolomite
dolomite really was uh
was the uh the predecessor to the eddie
murphy movies okay
eddie murphy was really redoing dolomite
just for a more modern audience and that
that's what that's what me and graham
grew up on we were watching [ __ ]
beverly hills got one and two three was
okay but
not as good as one two
and you know [ __ ]
i was big into eddie murphy i just
thought i just thought his movies were
[ __ ] great i mean i was watching his
[ __ ] up until even recently but i liked
[ __ ] vampire in brooklyn and
[ __ ] the golden child
yeah we i have the golden child i mean
jenny watched that not too long ago
honestly good movies i loved the golden
child growing up i saw it like a million
times when i watched it again recently i
didn't love it as much as i used to
but it's still a good movie trading
places trading places i need to get that
one i don't have it
uh but [ __ ] trading places is a good
one i mean the golden child is such a
weird
premise yeah i kind of feel like there
was like indiana jones yeah there was
this whole thing i guess it was like the
whole indiana jones thing but like in
the 80s there was this whole thing it's
like well
we're gonna do like a regular like
adventure movie but then we're gonna
have like all this weird like mystical
[ __ ] you know what i mean like big
trouble a little china stuff like that
where
it seems like grounded in reality but
they're like oh never mind like magic
exists like it's a real thing yeah
it was a lot of people
a lot of people have forgotten the
significance of eddie murphy
eddie murphy basically
single-handedly saved
saturday night live
because well he's easily like the funny
saturday night live was gonna be
canceled basically it sucked then he
showed up and basically saved it
um because the old crew had left at that
time
i remember when all that [ __ ] went down
and then his stand up his vhs or vcr
[ __ ] stand-up show was like [ __ ]
delirious and everything and raw and raw
they were great at the time they didn't
age well they're not as funny as they
used to be but well no comedy is well
hardly in it all the comedy doesn't age
that well but
i remember they were [ __ ] hilarious
in those days because he would say
things that people wouldn't say back
then he was he was the original kind of
like shock jock in a certain way
he was shocking about what he said what
he would say
and although gotta say richard pryor was
kind of he was following in richard
pryor's footsteps yeah and he like
acknowledged that he was a big fan of
like richard pryor and he also said that
[ __ ] um
he said that bill cosby was trying to
stop him from doing what he would do but
you know his stan eddie murphy's stand
up was okay i liked it
but it just man
his movies i for me were was what i
remember well he was just such a
charismatic like his personality was
just so
it was a dude you could see yourself
hanging out with i mean yeah and like
his charm was just very infectious yeah
which is a
you don't see that a lot and um he had a
real star quality yeah yeah which you
don't really see in a lot of people he
just he's very natural he's very natural
uh that kind of charm just like came
across
yeah he was young he was good looking
guy he was [ __ ] swift you know what i
mean he could come back with some cool
[ __ ] and he came up with some good ideas
and
and people loved him
you know and
he got some people say you know when he
came up with his own film when he when
he had his own studio
he started to get a little too
family-friendly and he kind of lose his
edge and i understand that you know well
he did do a lot of yeah he did the
haunted mansion and he had a lot of
killing disney but it wasn't bad that
material was not bad material um [ __ ]
coming to america was still great he had
a lot of good
solo projects
um yeah he did get a little
did get a little [ __ ] sedate but he
made a comeback that [ __ ] dolomite
movie that he killed was my name man i
got a dolomite is my name i got that
[ __ ] on blu-ray that's a [ __ ]
excellent movie god that was so good
yeah
now this now the sequel to um
coming to america coming to america was
good it was pg but it was good
i mean it was it was all right it was
all right
man the [ __ ] king
[ __ ] you know what i mean [ __ ]
james earl jones [ __ ] his comeback
tour
in when that character was [ __ ] he
just knocked out the park the king
willed himself to die
yeah
you see here this is what we're talking
about the king of zamunda death didn't
happen to him no
he allowed it he arranged the whole
thing of when he was gonna die in the
middle of the ceremony
he allowed himself to die
well that was like his last like he was
such a king that he was like i'm going
to tell you when i'm going to die yeah i
get that [ __ ] grave it's all like
part of the program yeah
i got a risky coming to america again
though i haven't seen that since even
back in the day
for a long time and it makes just
talking about this makes you want to see
beverly hills cop one two
just just for eddie in the soundtrack
yeah um what was the other two that
[ __ ] we had [ __ ] 48 hours and then
another 48 hours i got a 48 hours i
don't think i have and another 48. i
don't think i have this sequel we just
have the first one that's good for the
first hours because we just like
re-watched that yeah the 48 hours man
was a lot more raw than i remembered it
was the it was not the edit wasn't very
smooth it was it was good but it was not
a great
i want to see the sequel and see if it's
any better
and it is okay it not as good as [ __ ]
beverly hills cop one and two
i mean beverly hills cop is kind of like
the quintessential it's like watching a
music video i kind of feel like yeah
um
yeah dj maniac is like laughing about
bill cosby you cannot say [ __ ] in front
of people yeah
[Music]
but
in light of later allegations now
everything that he said is like creepy
yeah
and honestly the fact that he was so
um
the fact that he got so on black culture
like particularly like hip hop culture
oh these people with their these kids
with their pants around their ankles
blah blah blah any time somebody's like
moralizing like that yeah they got some
like [ __ ] [ __ ] to have t says she's
not she liked a vampire in brooklyn but
she's never seen beverly hills cop t go
ahead and check off goodness get the
[ __ ] out and you never okay look beverly
hills cop three is kind of a weak movie
it was not done right even eddie himself
says three wasn't wasn't very good one
and two were great
one is a huge [ __ ] hit
two was even more polished you gotta see
one and two
[ __ ] grandparents will tell you me
and [ __ ] me me and mike kowalski man
[ __ ] we would sit around we'd watch
that movie the both those movies over
and over again we're growing [ __ ]
eddie murphy was our [ __ ] hero
[ __ ] we just loved that dude back in
those days you know what's weird it's a
detroit based
movie about cops and it had eddie murphy
in it and they're going to
go into [ __ ] california so it's a
fish out of water thing
and i had
of course
born in california raised between
california mississippi and then moved to
michigan at that point so i kind of knew
i understood the difference between
detroit and california all right and
that's what this movie is about it's a
fish out of water story about a black
dude from detroit who's a [ __ ] good
cop who wasn't always a cop
okay
he didn't doesn't tell you what he was
before
but you can read between the lines that
he that he was a thug okay before he was
a cop he he's a detective but he's got
to go to [ __ ]
california he's got to go to california
to investigate who was to kill his his
friend that he grew up with his white
friend all right and they were in
organized crime together and he's trying
to figure out who it was that killed it
if it's just a great movie [ __ ] axel
foley was a great character
and we grew up with it you know
i mean to be honest i saw beverly hills
cop several times as a kid
i don't know why but like when i was
growing up
like for whatever reason
i was really like way into the golden
child i saw that like way more times
than beverly hills got i guess because
it had that weird like mystical aspect
to it too
like where there was like magical
realism [ __ ] going on yeah and i kind of
like
like i said i i didn't really realize it
at the time you didn't really think
about it at the time but in the 80s
there were a lot of [ __ ] movies like
that like you said big trouble in little
china stuff like that where it seemed
like just kind of on its surface it
seemed just kind of like a funny like
adventure farce yeah and then they're
like oh by the way magic is real yeah
you know what i mean which yeah tea if
you have very weird if you haven't seen
[ __ ] golden child you got to see that
one too but i would recommend seeing
golden child after
[ __ ] beverly hills cop because
beverly hills cop is not supernatural
all right yeah it's just like a regular
right it's a regular kind of adventure
movie about a [ __ ] cop
but then later when you get into [ __ ]
when you get into [ __ ] um
golden child
it's a guy who's kind of like axel foley
but he's just some dude who's he's like
he's an activist and he's he finds
missing children yeah that's it and he
kind of makes fun of the fact on
television that he finds missing
children which is a little weird but
it's kind of weird
how do you make a living finding missing
children but he's kind of like the kind
of like uh kind of like indiana jones he
ends up going on this international
adventure
to find it to find this
well it's a missing child and a dagger
and a shantae dagger [ __ ] but it's
it's a relic and he's dealing with
demons and all kinds of stuff it's a
good movie
it's a fun movie very fun well he's kind
of like going to
bed right going to go to tibet right to
find a kid
and there's like a whole thing about
like it's a dalai lama type of situation
yeah
so and like i said there's some
supernatural [ __ ] going on
cheryl tell tina to ignore me that i'm
always kicking her out too yeah i kick
you
if a person hasn't seen a key movie
in the history of [ __ ] america
all right i don't talk about just
the the south this is just the entire
union all right because [ __ ] we were
watching that [ __ ] in the south and in
the north
[ __ ]
you know beverly hills cop and a golden
child that's just universal that's some
that's some american [ __ ] right there if
you're in europe you have to see those
movies they will help you understand the
character of america america all right
and then there were [ __ ] great movies
and there were movies of their time
they were basically small movies
they had a lot of talented and very good
writing
uh made by a small team of people that
had a vision and it was to pump out
these basically low budget movies that
had real tight stories that made a [ __ ]
ton of money when they got to the box
office
they made a lot of money
they had real good soundtracks good
editing good stories and um
very quick editing
and their adventures you know they're
just
they're a product of their time and they
were good times
i want to say you know something that
always kind of like fascinated me and
and i know that we have some like brits
in the chat
um i know this because i was married to
a british person for a very long time
uh there is a subset of british people
that were super super into american
action films yeah
in the 1980s they [ __ ] like my
ex-husband and he's not the only one
because it was a [ __ ] sound of like
during the video uh store era
they [ __ ] loved anything that was
like [ __ ] chuck norris or john claude
van damme or
you know charles bronson
rape revenge movies any of that kind of
[ __ ] they [ __ ] ate it up
and i just like i thought that was like
so [ __ ] interesting and it's like i
don't know like from a sociological
point of view i find that very very
fascinating like i like those movies too
but
i thought it was interesting how there
was kind of like a subset of
british people that were like really
really into those
um
and i'm you know i guess i can see why
but i don't know it's it's interesting
to me that
that that's like uh that that was such a
thing my ex-husband was like super he
was welsh by the way but um
he was super into chuck norris movies
and charles bronson movies and he was
really really into like 70s rape revenge
like he loved like abel ferrara um you
know like ms 45 and all that kind of
stuff
and
so he loved like gritty like new york
slasher movies he loved like you know he
liked italian like giallo movies and
stuff too like lucio folgi and all that
but
um i just thought that was very
interesting how he was really into like
american action movies and i kind of
feel like there is still
uh
from what i could determine from other
like youtubers that i've looked at
other british people
of the same age as me or maybe like a
little bit younger that are really
really into like american 80s 70s and
80s
action movies and horror movies and i
don't know why i find that so
interesting but i really really do and
i'm not really sure why that's a thing
but it apparently is
uh wayne dalton says golden child has a
really cool stop frame animation of a
dancing cocaine
wait does it
do i remember that i can't remember
but
we bought it like i said i saw it like a
zillion times because
i don't know i've said this on the show
before but
um when i was growing up
my dad worked for cablevision so from
very very early like from the late 70s
early 80s we had all the cable channels
because we got them for free
so we had hbo we had cinemax we had
showtime we had all the ones that were
available we had mtv from when it first
started uh we had all that kind of [ __ ]
from when i was a little kid
and when hbo and cinemax and [ __ ] like
that first started in the early 80s i
think as far as i can recall
um
you know they didn't have a lot of
movies that they had access to because
of like rights issues and stuff
so what they would do is that they would
have like a handful of movies
for every month and they would just like
replay them so sometimes you'd see like
the same three or four movies
every day pretty much and then like on
weekends they'd have some other ones so
i ended up seeing like the same movies
this is how i ended up seeing sergeant
pepper's lonely heart skull band time
after time
uh
the pirate movie grease 2
movies like that this is how i ended up
seeing them like probably like 400 times
because they just showed them like all
the time they were always on like every
time you flipped over to that channel it
was always [ __ ] on
but uh yeah so there was that whole
thing um she said she just moved very
hills cop up to number one yeah you guys
see
you don't have to see three but one and
two are [ __ ] great two
is even better than one but one sets the
stage
and then later after that you want to
see
golden child
it's a weird one it's a weird movie
golden child is kind of like eddie
murphy doing
raiders of the lost ark and big trouble
in little china it has that yeah it's
like that kind of vibe to it it's that
kind of vibe and it's there there are
great movies dude these are small budget
movies but they're punching way above
way above uh of their weight
we love them we [ __ ] love you know
it's weird he loved him movies like
golden child i saw that back when it
came out or when it ever came out of
cable like a year after it came out in
theater i didn't think the whole premise
of it i didn't think about the premise
of it being weird at the time
but when we re-watched it like a few
months ago i was like this is a weird
movie yeah it didn't occur to me that it
was weird at the time
golden child has
adventure in it
it's got a romance
uh but it has paranormal supernatural
and demonic elements yeah he's fighting
demons from another dimension yeah and
but they're not christian demons they're
buddhist demons
uh because he's dealing with stuff up in
the [ __ ] himalayas
and the golden child is a [ __ ] he's
kind of a book buddhist
uh
religious icon he's he's kind of like
their version of the [ __ ]
of the messiah and uh these these
buddhist demons are trying to get him to
basically
desanctify himself
by consuming blood
and they got him in a damn cage
you just got to see it it's a [ __ ]
weird movie it is it has a lot of dark
tone to it in a certain way but then you
got eddie murphy in there kind of being
imagine what how eddie murphy would try
to kind of be
like a
like indiana jones to deal with to deal
with this [ __ ] this weird [ __ ]
situation yeah yeah yeah yeah which is
how most of us would probably do without
putting being put into this right and
he's got this weird hot tibetan chick
that's helping him and he's trying to
hit but she keeps turning him down
that's part of the [ __ ] thing too
he's like but you know and then she's
like uh she tries to brush his ass
i mean because they're trying to be
buddhist about stuff
but um no it's a great movie great movie
and uh it is a lot of fun great movies
it's weird but it's a lot of fun came
out when i was in high school and we
just grew up with it and it was just
yeah what year came out uh probably
about 86 85 86 right on top yeah it was
something like that i think i was in
junior higher high school when it came
out i can't remember
startup 78 says invasion usa is
brilliant chuck norris is uh 80's
christmas movie set in south florida
it's glorious yeah oh my god i've seen
like so many [ __ ] what was the one
where chuck norris
wasn't there when we went to hell at
some point i kind of feel like my
ex-husband made me watch it i don't like
i've maybe blocked it out but maybe
y'all can help me out with that
um let me see tito says we recommended
time after time too she loved it old
seven you saw dammit i love
that movie
i will defend that movie to the death
it's a good one it's so [ __ ] good
malcolm mcdowell's in that [ __ ] uh you
know david warner is in it playing jack
the ripper yeah
jack the ripper comes to 1979
in h.g wells time machine if that
doesn't make you want to watch the movie
i don't know what the [ __ ] is the matter
with you but it's really really good
mary stephen virgin is in it too
so so good i love that somewhere in time
was good too that was just that was
christopher reeve yeah i really really
like that movie time traveling
[ __ ] time traveling through his
mind mr 88 says i know i'm completely
alone in this but i loved greece too and
could not sit through greece i said
earlier we like to um i love greece the
first one but i also love greece too and
i know that people are trying to like
maybe feel bad about that maybe but i
love [ __ ] grease too it's good it's
okay it's good i mean michelle pfeiffer
um not a great singer gotta say but she
[ __ ] went at it with gusto and
honestly i used to have the soundtrack
of grease 2 on vinyl
yeah um there's some [ __ ] great songs
in there reproduction probably being the
best one
but uh yeah i honestly they they have so
long song about bowling
yeah there was like it's a fun ass movie
now khan says he's he'd be honest i've
never seen a 1980s jeffrey combs movie
until he subscribed to this channel i
don't know which one you saw if you saw
a [ __ ] well hopefully it was
reanimation all the entire reanimator
series is good
from beyond is also good oh yeah that's
also a good one yeah from beyonce i mean
anything with stuart gordon directing
yeah is going to be a good time yeah
it's going to be a good time honestly i
will watch anything with jeffrey combs
in it no i [ __ ] love jeffrey if
you've seen those movies you also want
to see dagon even though jeffrey combs
isn't in it it's that same studio if i
remember correctly yeah yeah uh dagon is
another [ __ ] lovecraftian movie it's
one of the most lovecraftian lovecraft
movies that i've ever seen and i think
like a lot of people [ __ ] on it like at
the time but
i don't know why i was like to me this
seems like way more in the spirit of a
lovecraft story yeah thank a lot of
other lovecraft adaptations they got a
cute spanish girl in it who's like queen
of the sea
trying to get back today i still want to
do that as a halloween costume one year
i gotta have a wheelchair
yeah well i need to get a wheelchair i
need to make like the crown yeah you
know what i mean t saw time after time
okay good yeah she said yeah kind of
time is pretty good i've seen since i
was a kid
that was one of the movies i saw that so
many times on cable when i was growing
up that i think even now i think i have
it memorized
um
i mean just
the whole premise of that is so [ __ ]
great
like i said
jack the ripper comes to 1979 in h.g
wells time machine and h.g wells has to
like come to 1979 to like stop
jack the ripper from killing people in
1979
so it's a fish out of water story but
it's also like a serial killer story
and
i don't know i just thought it was like
really [ __ ] well done yeah all the
acting in it's fantastic it's just like
really good and honestly it has like a
lot of like deeper meaning about
jack the ripper
uh
you know and he even says this out right
in the movie right where it's like you
know in 1888 when he was killing people
he was like oh back then i was an
anomaly
but in 1979 like nobody even notices you
know what i mean like because violence
is such a like big part of like the
culture or whatever so it's kind of like
making like a bigger
there's a bigger like thematic like
thrust to it and i thought that was like
really cool actually it's not like
heavy-handed or anything but i really
like that they kind of went there with
that now t when you get on when you get
on beverly hills cop i know you got that
at the top
one and two
you're basically dealing with a similar
tone
as uh
as a karate kid
which is
very positive upbeat adventure movie
uh but this is a police adventure
and a uh detective movie you'll like it
you'll like uh i think everybody in the
[ __ ] audience everybody in the
comment section will tell you beverly
hills cop series is
[ __ ] top-notch now it it has aged a
bit
you know these were low-budget
productions of the time
but the but the tone was just spot-on
and the storytelling the dialogue the
acting
very much products of the time
very positive kind of feel good movies
that had
adventure in them
and i guess you could say attention
there's tension in the story
good guys versus bad guys
nothing
real complicated though you know i mean
it's just uh kind of comfort movies
great soundtrack man sound both those
movies
you might as well just listen to a
badass 80s album
that's kind of like what it's listening
to
uh fun a lot of fun and then you'll like
golden child too that's another good one
those three one two and golden child
that's that's your homework you'll love
it
yeah tila says uh time after time was
truly inventive i loved it it was a
beautiful love story yeah honestly um
you know what's awesome about that was
that malcolm mcdowell and mary
steenburgen
met on the set of that movie
and they got married so they actually
like fell in love for real like while
that was going on and i think that
really like came across like in the
movie which was nice rebecca says all i
remember movie wise in the 80s is star
wars and horror films
there was so much good [ __ ] in the 80s
there was so much good [ __ ] in the 80s
just just talking about those three
murphy movies those who kind of tear up
and [ __ ] i don't want to see them
tomorrow man [ __ ] i'm gonna see he's
getting emotional getting emotional
getting emotional yeah uh tila says
michelle pfeiffer in what lies beneath
so good oh yeah
i've honestly i've been wanting to
rewatch that because i think i saw it
come up on a streaming service the other
day
i saw that in the theater i think
and that was actually good because that
was one of the first times that i'd ever
seen harrison ford
playing a bad guy
you know what i mean um and
so it was really good it's a really it's
a thriller and it was really really good
so that's another one that i have to
like re-watch she also says yeah dagon
is really good yeah dango is great i
mean uh yeah and somebody like i think
dj maniac says uh that dagon was a
really good yeah dagon
it's not an adaptation of the hp
lovecraft story dagon it's actually an
adaptation of shadow over in smith yeah
um but it it takes like some stuff from
dagon but it's mostly shadow of rand
smith is what it is
um but like i said it's one of the most
it's weird because they made so many
lovecraft
adaptations that made somebody like love
crafty in movies
and a lot of them don't
give me the same feeling that i get when
i read a lovecraft story
dagon was one of the first movies that
said this is how i feel when i read a
lovecraft story this is very
lovecraft to me in the sense that this
gives me the same vibe that i get when i
read a lovecraft story you know what i'm
saying yeah um
so i so i don't know but it was one of
the first movies that gave me that
[ __ ] vibe and i'm not saying that
like some of the other lovecraft
adaptations aren't good because they are
but
as far as
the thing that gave me the same feeling
that i got from reading his stories
dagon is like up there
it's i think it's one of the ones that
captured his
lovecraft's vibe at least like for me
um
more closely than any other one
um kind of also they're just talking
about the hellraiser movies i think the
fantasy
yeah every phantasm was good
i liked all the phantasm movies i mean
obviously the the second one's my
favorite yeah um
but
honestly they're all worth watching yeah
they're all he says she's gonna have
[ __ ] beverly hills cop one of two on
for tonight you're gonna love those
movies they're good they're good they're
real good
they're just
good
solid flicks
from the
time and the [ __ ] music
man it makes you want to see him now
although i probably fall asleep at him
as drunk as i am
yeah i probably would but
tomorrow they're just uh they kind of
bring back a time when i was young and
watching this and just you you'll see
you'll see you'll you'll tila will it
will you will really you'll understand
him when you see him
yeah let's kind of talk about that
though because i kind of feel like
i like a lot of movies from the 70s and
80s i like a lot of movies that i grew
up with
but
sometimes not always like sometimes i
you know i've liked those movies the
whole time and i still think they're
good but sometimes movies that i was
really into in the 70s or 80s and i
didn't see them for a long time and then
i see them nowadays
sometimes i watch them now and i'm like
what the [ __ ] was i even thinking or
that wasn't as good as i remembered it
being
so i'm
i don't know i'm like really interested
in how like nostalgia
colors people's perceptions of things
now i'm not saying i don't think that's
always the case because a lot of movies
from the 80s that i loved back then if i
watch them now i still love them yeah
but some movies that i loved back then
but i haven't seen for a long time and
then i watch it now i'm just kind of
like what the [ __ ] was i even thinking
like that's terrible
but um you know what i mean
uh so i'm kind of interested how much
like nostalgia
i don't know i kind of feel like
as a person i'm not a super nostalgic
person yeah um
so i don't know that's something that
like really kind of interests me about
movies and uh specifically because
i know people have like warm feelings
about movies that they grew up watching
yeah and then sometimes when they watch
them later they're like what the [ __ ]
it's like not good now t says she's
gonna give a review of the [ __ ]
beverly hills cop movies next on the
next stream i don't think we've ever
reviewed them have we we probably should
review them i don't think we have
actually we actually should we probably
should do a review do you have all of
them i got all three of them okay i
thought you did um
yeah
okay
maybe we should review them because i
want to see them tomorrow
well okay we can watch it and we'll
watch them tomorrow because we did we
did we did charles bronze and we did
like three of those so we should
probably do those well do you want to do
like each one like okay so we'll do each
movie separately okay so we're doing you
separately so we can watch him like so
we can do one sunday
okay so that's fine we'll watch it
that's fine yeah um
yeah yeah they're good movies
boy what am i what i was going to say
something about it
well i was talking about nostalgia okay
yeah in movies and i was that is that
helping you yeah sometimes the nostalgia
does not hold up
but in the case of the beverly hills cop
movies it does hold
up saw i saw him recently and i'm like
oh man these things are better than i
remember them well yeah i will say too
that sometimes
i saw some movies on cable back in the
80s and i was like oh that's good
whatever and then like i rewatched it
recently i'm like oh my god that was
like better than i remembered right so
some movies
while i liked him back in the day and
then i saw him nowadays and i'm just
like now i watch it and i'm just kind of
like okay whatever but
some movies that i was like not super
like a fan of back in the 80s
and then i watch it nowadays i'm like oh
my god that was a lot better than i
remembered so it's i don't know i like
to think i'm trying to like stay
objective about the [ __ ] because i
really don't want to be one of those
people that just like stuff because
that was what i watched when i was
growing up
because that doesn't always
mean that it's good you know what i'm
saying
so
i don't know i'm really kind of like
cognizant of that
this is why i try to like watch stuff
that i loved back in the old days
i want to watch it now because i'm just
interested i'm interested to see how i'm
going to react to it nowadays now that
i'm an old [ __ ] yeah a lot of stuff
i'm talking about here i have seen it in
recent times it was better yeah same
i've checked up on it right most of the
time
i think the [ __ ] is either still good
like it still like holds up i still like
it as much
sometimes i like it better
on rare occasions i watch stuff that i
loved back in the old days and then i
was just kind of like what the [ __ ] was
i thinking about that because that's
terrible right not usually though well
it was kind of like going back and
seeing [ __ ] um
transfers
went back and watched transfers and then
[ __ ] was unwatchable i was like i can't
believe that see i hadn't seen that back
in the old days and you kept talking
about it you're like we need to watch
that because that was something that
like you were really into back in the
old days yeah
i had never seen it and scanners 2 was
unwatchable but i remembered liking that
yeah i will yeah and honestly and also
um
howling too my sister is a werewolf
unwatchable
i remember kind of liking that yeah like
it wasn't a favorite or anything but i
kind of remember liking it back in the
old days when it was on cable we tried
to watch it again recently and i'm just
like this is i can't watch this yeah
like i think after 15 minutes we turned
it off yeah because i'm just like i'm
not wasting my time but uh but yeah
most of the time
if i loved something really loved it
from back and then back in the old days
if i watch it nowadays it's usually
still good usually
but
so that's good i mean like my taste was
at least
decent
when i was a child so that's kind of
something to be celebrated i suppose
uh
cheryl says jenny is so easy going it's
amazing it makes me feel like such a
[ __ ] and honestly no she's a [ __ ] too
oh yeah
honestly i wish i was more of a [ __ ]
because
if you're and i'm gonna say like i i
don't mind being easygoing and laid back
and [ __ ] but it's like you can't be like
too much like that or people like
[ __ ]
walk all over you
um so you have to be like a little bit
of a [ __ ] or you're not going to like
get anything you want in this [ __ ]
lady there's only 34.
holy crap i thought she was a lot older
than that holy [ __ ] don't feel so old
well that's why she doesn't know these
movies we're talking about oh yeah
you're about that's good that's good
though yeah i mean you know yeah uncle
tom's [ __ ] troll
uncle tom's teaching you history
[ __ ] go back you'll see it these are
good movies these are good movies i mean
look
jenny and i have spoken about this
[ __ ] many times
every year a certain amount of movies
come out
theater of course
movie theaters is part of american
tradition
culture it's like that in every country
because of where we are over england and
parts of europe also they they work
their way into this
most of these movies [ __ ] suck
most of them [ __ ] suck i mean from
every era from every area from every
area they come out they're shown people
immediately forget about them but there
are some of them that you remember and
it's because the place the time the way
the culture was who made the movie
the vibe of the time
so
a lot of times when me and jenny will
bend over back and say look watch this
one or watch this one these are usually
iconic movies
that [ __ ] help you
feel
in your heart what those times were like
even if you didn't live in them
now you won't feel them the way we do
because we were there so we remember
what the feeling was like the only thing
we can do is try to insert that feeling
into you and maybe you could try to vibe
with it but a lot of times you have to
watch it a couple times to get that into
it
but uh like we were just talking about
beverly hills cop
my interpretation of it is going to be
different than yours because i was there
at the time
but if you watch it a couple times and
you get into the [ __ ] music of the
story you'd be able to imagine it and
place yourself back in those times the
feeling that is portrayed in these
movies is accurate
those feelings are accurate
that [ __ ] didn't happen
but that's what it felt like
it's fantasy it's fantasy the thing
about it though is i kind of feel like
maybe maybe yeah
i have a better
perspective on it because i like
silent movies yeah and i like stuff from
like the 1920s and 1930s obviously i was
not alive back then
but when i watched those movies
i tried to cast myself i wasn't alive
back then so i will never know what it
was like to live back then but i do kind
of like try to cast myself into that
mindset
while i'm watching it yeah so
maybe other people can do that too like
when they're watching stuff that was not
uh
you know
that's not like from when they were
alive
uh hugo says
i just saw heathers yeah it's pretty
good still yeah heather is
is so [ __ ] good honestly
heather's came out when i was
in my last year of high school
so
it was set in high school
so me and all my friends like really
vibed with that um
i was just like oh my god this is like i
can't believe somebody made this movie
it was just kind of like that yeah so
i'm very happy to see that like
other people that didn't grow up in that
same time period are so like vibes it's
a weird movie it's a good movie
i mean
it was a weird mixture of like teen
movie and murder
it's a very very very dark comedy
honestly it reads a lot differently
nowadays because nowadays we have a lot
more high school shootings under our
belt
than we did in 1990 when it came out
um
so it might
it might hit different there's some
about that movie in lost boys that for
some reason they're totally different
kind of for me i kind of associate the
two it might remind me just although
lost boys came out three years before
before yeah 87 or something about the
way that they were that they kind of
associate those two because i was in
lost boys was good too i was a sophomore
sophomore in high school when lost boys
came out t go ahead and put go ahead and
put golden child in in that queue also
watch that one too you'll like it uh
started 78 also uh mentions the princess
bride which is honestly that's one of my
favorite movies
ever that movie is so [ __ ] good
you've never seen the princess bride
have you ever i think i have
did you see that what was that about
what was it about it's like a fairy tale
but
it sounds familiar the dread pirate
roberts yeah i'm just like saving yeah
but it's like it's a parody of like
fairy tales a little bit
um but yeah it's really really really
[ __ ] good it's really good
but um
wayne dalton brings up uh the hidden
from 1987. i remember that one that was
the great retro horror movie yeah
alien thing and the terminator yeah
remember that one that was a good one i
saw that as well
i think
hold on let me think i saw that in the
theater let me let me go ahead and
pander for some super chats [ __ ] uh
jenny jenny didn't get any super chats
tonight if you guys would now is the
time if you guys want tip go ahead and
drop it in the [ __ ] well i don't know if
it's working zach said it wasn't working
he said it's not working it may not be
working well he well that was like a
long time
all right that was on like with the
other chat we ain't getting anything
tonight it's okay though i can we'll
we'll have another stream later but uh
later on in the week
we got uh i got that [ __ ] channel
masala down there
chickpea curry
and fork we bought an air fryer yeah
which i was reading an article today
they're like why do like why do people
call it an air fryer it's not really a
fryer it's like a convection it's like a
convection is what it is
so he made
like a pork roast or like a pork
shoulder what was that no no portion one
pork tenderloin in it
and like he served that with rice
and broccoli that had grown outback yeah
and that [ __ ] was fantastic
that was delicious oh we got a super
chat thank you
okay look at you like crying poor
yeah i'm crying for
well it's a business you know what i
mean thank you ian thank you
tila says golden child oh here comes
some more thank you tila we'll try to
watch this weekend it's a weird ass
movie it is weird which one golden child
it's not weird as you think it is
it's an indiana jones movie
it's uh yeah in the context of the time
it wasn't i didn't think it was weird at
the time but when i watched it nowadays
i'm like this is really weird yeah it
has a lot of dark it has a lot of dark
undertones kind of [ __ ] satanic
supernatural [ __ ] you got you got eddie
murphy in a satanic occult movie but
he's kind of funny in it
and he fights demons
i want a knife
[Laughter]
yeah
i don't know why i remember that more
than anything i wanted knife yeah
yeah
but there's just a lot of good [ __ ] i
want to see that one again
see
noon spa was the [ __ ] demon's name
remember that yeah yeah charles uh
charles dance was that actually saying i
think
he was in a lot of stuff in the 80s yeah
and yeah
yeah you'll like that one
i'm just i'm talking to t's a long time
friend on the show but i'm saying
everybody those are good movies
um and
if you've never seen them then you're
really missing out on american culture
[ __ ]
there's a lot of job there it's kind of
like look if you're very american look
if you're in a movies
and you want to
be kind of like up on movies in general
thank you david june thank you very much
people thank you um
then there are certain movies from every
decade that you have to see yeah
um
and i'm kind of like deficient a little
bit in that i do try to like
see all the main movies from every
decade i don't have a lot of time but i
do try to like
like i said i love silent movies i love
[ __ ] from the 20s and 30s so i have seen
a lot of stuff from then yeah um so i do
kind of like try to especially horror
movies i try to see all the [ __ ] from
like the 50s 50s 60s you know even back
to the 40s 20s whatever so i try to see
all that stuff
but
there are some movies that you kind of
need to see and like the 80s yeah i do
kind of yeah you do kind of feel yeah
to be like up on all the cultural
relevance or whatever you do kind of you
will understand those decades thank you
very much cheryl it's okay sure we know
you broke you get us later babe
yeah don't worry we're not coming down
we're not like we're not stressing you
all out we're just trying to give you
jenny some tips
keep the show rolling supporting the
show thank you very much everybody's
coming through
cheryl says betty davis is badass yeah
honestly sometimes
i watch
those movies with like betty davis or
something like that
and i'm just kind of like
i don't know that's kind of like
aspirational is that [ __ ] up i don't
know what movie she's talking about
rebecca she goes got the whole set i
love watching them we don't know what
movies you're talking about baby thank
you thank you elio elio she's in on let
me know this training team there you go
thank you very much everybody
thank you very much
strong 78 says tila you haven't seen
beetlejuice she hasn't seen beetlejuice
what the [ __ ] that's it shut the [ __ ]
shut up
shut the [ __ ] down i am leaving no we're
just kidding
that's another good one that's another
real good one honestly like i said
i forget sometimes yeah this is what
happens you get old
you forget that some people are like
younger than you yeah and they grew up
with a whole different like cultural
zeitgeist i haven't seen the same [ __ ]
that you have
i mean
because to me like in our uh
the way we grew up like heathers
beetlejuice [ __ ] like that that was like
everybody had to [ __ ] see that i mean
i feel like
if you were of a certain bent
as i was and all the people that i hung
out with all the weirdos
everybody saw that [ __ ] yeah holy crap
good movie good movie um
not my favorite movie from from him but
it's it's a good movie
good movie my favorite movie from him
was [ __ ] ed wood
i kind of feel like probably i mean it
goes back and forth i do love
beetlejuice i do um but ed wood god damn
that [ __ ] movie is so good yeah and
it's not a [ __ ] mainstream movie
i saw that in the theater too it's it's
a it's a real life story about ed wood
who's a [ __ ] movie director t if you
haven't seen ed wood that's another one
but you got to see
it's
i really do it's about i love it it's
all in black and white okay and it in
it's about a [ __ ] movie director from
the [ __ ] 50s named edward who made
these [ __ ] planned nine from outer
space and all these [ __ ] low-budget
movies
and
i love it because
he
tim burton um clearly grew up with a
love for these types of movies
he didn't
um try to cheat
she's not saying [ __ ] about movies
anymore
no it's okay
it's good approached ed woods good
enough the man yeah even though edward
was a flawed human being yeah
but he did approach him very
sympathetically right and he approached
him as like a very well-meaning yeah man
like you know what i mean and so i think
the movie
even though it's very funny and there's
like some [ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ] in it
but it does have like a really good
heart to it yeah and i think that's what
makes it work 50s underground hollywood
yeah that's what it's about and it was
people with like zero budget that were
making movies in the 1950s ed wood was a
real man he was a [ __ ] a marine who
fought on the island of peli lou
saw a lot of action in world war ii
wanted to be a horror sci-fi movie
director and he was a cross-dresser
he just had this
when that was really not accepted he
just [ __ ] had when he was under a lot
of stress he had to put on an angora
sweater and some nylons and some paint
some shoes shirts and panties and he had
to keep all this hidden from his
girlfriends he was straight i mean i
don't know why anybody would want to
wear like uncomfortable girl clothes
yeah like when they're but you know you
do and he didn't have any teeth he got
his [ __ ] teeth knocked out in the war
so he wore false teeth
and he and he had all these freaky
friends and he was friends with bella
lugosi towards the end of bella's life
when he was a junkie and all kind and
they would steal [ __ ] from studios to
make movies it's a great movie i mean
vampire girl
story yeah yeah in a weird [ __ ] up way
ed wood
ed wood the great movie and uh an
examination of the human spirit
and and poor ed was a good man real good
man yeah he seemed like a yeah he's a
good man and i mean he did degenerate
into like doing porn and [ __ ] later but
like i said i don't even want to say
that he's degenerating he just needed
money yeah
i mean porn isn't that
that's where the market was that
suggests that like porn is like lesser
which it's not really it wasn't even the
porn as you would know today it was
nudie films which is topless dancing
yeah that's what he got into yeah
but that's where the money was at the
time and the money was going away and he
ended up dying and basically in a little
bitty la apartment [ __ ] with [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] on the floor and everywhere and
you know he he he
you know [ __ ] his career didn't work
out but it's a really good movie about
him you know real good movie about him
it's a very loving tribute yeah
yeah um
and it's kind of heartwarming in a way
it is yeah it is
it's sad
but
um
yeah i like that
they didn't like tim burton didn't
you could tell that he had a lot of love
for the genre and he had a lot of love
for the man
and so he didn't like want to exploit
him necessarily
um
so he made this like lovely
kind of like heartwarming tribute which
is still like blackly funny they're
laughing about plan not from outer space
and cheryl says yeah poor dude died
teddyless i mean yeah he did he died
honestly that but that's we could all go
that way we don't know how we're gonna
die
[ __ ] like that makes me really sad
because i kind of feel like i wish that
ed wood
had lived long enough to see that his
his work that his work
yeah would was like had a resurgence i
grew up with seeing that [ __ ] on channel
13 out in california
because
how happy that would have been 34
channel 13
monster matinee they'd put [ __ ] sure
ed wood movies on there like planned
nine and they were kind of the monster
they would scare me as a kid in a way
you know like five or six years like oh
but you know mean that was edward
california [ __ ] and
it was funny uh looking back on it did
they ever show glenn or glenda no i
didn't see that one yeah i'm pretty sure
they probably know that was it that was
a cross dress that was the cross
dressing now they just showed the horror
once with torah johnson coming up out of
the ground yeah
oh yeah [ __ ] tour but uh
he was in some uh he was in some but he
was in [ __ ]
uh
what's that [ __ ] other fucker's name
i'll think of it he was in [ __ ]
atlanta time forgot
great movie well he was in a lot of
stuff he was in uh coleman francis he
was in um a coleman francis movie also
like as the monster yeah so
he was a wrestler straw dog says i
haven't seen barbarian where a lot of
these movies everyone's talking about
yeah okay look if you haven't seen these
movies
in the newer movie segment that i'm
talking about you want to see vivarium
and art artists self-defense
okay
in the older movies you want to see
you want to see um
[ __ ] beverly hills cop one and two
there is a three but that's optional see
those cop one and two and then see
golden child and you'll be kind of up on
what we're we've talked about a lot of
stuff but those are the main those are
the main five
you'll you'll enjoy them they're good
those are good movies
dj maniac says even myself is a
connoisseur of horror
i haven't seen everything i'm expected
to have at my age and i'm not
about to start rattling them off like
too many smallmouth right all my points
um honestly i
i try to like see all the best stuff
from every decade but there are still
some like gaps in my knowledge but i'm
trying to like uh catch up on it now
straw dogs you want my throat [ __ ]
number six would be uh edward we're
talking about it edward's a good one too
what was that 94 1994 94 i think yeah
that's uh tim burton uh
uh [ __ ] who else is in that again uh
uh landau martin luther now oh [ __ ] got
an oscar nom yeah martin lantern
should have won i don't think he won but
martin landau plays bella
because that was one of the roles that i
forgot yeah that that was actually not
the actual person right and it's it's
it's supposed to be taking place in the
50s it's all black and white it feels
like you're watching an old black and
white horror movie
from the 50s and it's just these
hollywood losers trying to [ __ ]
hollywood loser has-beens trying to
[ __ ] make a name for themselves in
horror
with no money
sorry it's great it's a great i just
thought of like johnny depp going we
don't have a permit run
they're stealing [ __ ] props and [ __ ]
from the theater from from from studios
i mean i think i loved ed wood the same
reason that i love dolomite as my name
yeah dolomites because i love
scrappy underdogs
like trying to like [ __ ] piece some
[ __ ] together and do some awesome [ __ ]
like when they don't have any resources
so
i think that's what like edward like
really resonated with me i think
um yeah that's i don't know i i guess
that's why
tina says yeah i lost cool points
tonight you all look and learn about the
movie i guess that i mean you know it's
a that's thank you you're like you're
young you're yeah you're many years
younger than us and it's like even i
haven't seen all the movies i feel like
i should have right and i kind of feel
bad about it
um not just movies but books i should
have read by this point i've read a lot
of the books you're supposed to read but
34 you're a baby
yeah yeah for you know it's you're not
going to know but dude i'm almost 50 and
it's just like i'm still 20 years on you
dude i got like i got stacks i got
[ __ ] lists yeah i got all kind of
[ __ ] i gotta like watch i get all kind
of [ __ ] i'm gonna read we came from an
era where movies were a lot more
important back then because we didn't
have social media our social media was
these movies well there weren't a lot of
other
right uh outlets
sure
so options you know so movies were kind
of like the way that you like related to
other well movies and music yeah that
was kind of like that was our social
media sure
so
it's not as important nowadays because
everything is just so everything
competes with
diffuse yeah so
i so i'll give like a lot of younger
people a pass because it's like there's
no way you can keep up with all that
there's no way you could keep it i can't
keep up with it you're right i haven't
even seen all the [ __ ] that came out
when i was a kid yeah you know what i
mean there's i'm still like discovering
ships like oh with this 80s movie i just
i didn't i never saw that
yeah gotta see that yeah and it's like
so there's still like a lot of [ __ ] i
gotta catch up on so i can't like [ __ ]
on [ __ ] millennials or younger for
not having seen that because i haven't
even seen the [ __ ]
you know how long we've been streaming
this stream held up man that's what it
was is that [ __ ]
land cable
land cables what that was
it made a big difference well now we
know yeah
tomorrow
i will order
a longer one
yeah or a patch cable or a patch and
like another yeah another five ten feet
because that really does seem too yeah
that's what it was helped that's what it
was
so that's good um why don't we go ahead
and shut this down and i'll uh start
making something to eat you gonna make
some food i got some china dog and some
more uh pork down there
you guys this air fryer that we bought
yeah it's really paying dividends yeah
you made all kind of good [ __ ] in it
yeah i'm gonna get another uh freezer
too
that refrigerator down there is not
working well yeah that's it we have
another refrigerator in the garage yeah
and i just need the freezer not the
refrigerator it's old and it's starting
to like uh
starting to [ __ ] the better so i got to
get another refrigerator near the
freezer there's a freezer and get for
400 i think i'm gonna get that
but it'll be here in two weeks which
means we gotta make that turkey
i got all the pork
turkey's not [ __ ] fully frozen i mean
it's partially frozen but you can't
store it like that i gotta make that
turkey well if we okay so we can just
eat the rest of the pork the pork's
frozen
no the pork that i made no the pork you
made that yeah yeah
we'll eat that how much of that is left
about that much
okay so we'll eat that over the next
couple days i'm gonna make a turkey then
make that turkey yeah make a turkey i'll
make it and then i'll because i'll eat
turkey okay
all week long i don't care i love turkey
that turkey was from last thanksgiving
or frozen they were cheap so i i make
sandwiches i'll throw it on salad i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll eat it for like
[ __ ] weeks all right it's fine all
right i gotta make some stuff again i
gotta make some and then get some
stuffing
make everything out of that old fridge
okay and then we'll throw that old
fridge away yeah and then get a new
freezer yeah and then yeah so there's
that okay all right so
hallelujah yes [ __ ] thing hold up
held up
i guess because we did the cable it's
the cable i'm going to get a longer
cable now we know now we know now we
know it's nice i'm going to get a longer
cable so we can like go all the way down
to like downstairs
and uh hopefully that will like help out
but yeah i'm very happy that that worked
out you're then we'll call them and have
them put another [ __ ] uh thing up
here up here because yeah that would
help too
probably yeah it would absolutely have
them put another [ __ ] router up here
yeah all right all right call them and
ask if they can put to calm tomorrow
first and see if they can put another
router and how much that would cost all
right we'll see if they're there because
tomorrow's saturday but also
okay if they're home because that's
that's that's the the correct way to do
it
would it be enough would it be to put
another i'm drunk i'm trying to talk i'm
[ __ ] hiccup in the car the correct
thing to do would be have them put
another router up here yeah but we'll
see i don't know if they'll do that okay
but if they can't i'll just get a longer
one of those yeah okay
all right so
everybody for yeah hanging out with us
yeah had a good time this evening i
could go honestly go watch them movies
you'll love them we'll probably watch
that tonight we'll see we'll see i would
love to see that
which one grab the hills
okay yeah i'd love to see that we can do
that yeah it's not a golden shop it's
only nine so yeah it's early so it's
like yeah it's fine
uh so yeah thanks for hanging out with
us this friday evening and we will see
you on sunday afternoon talking about
some movie we don't know what we won yet
but we'll
we'll figure something out uh so thanks
for dropping by thanks for super chats
and we will see you guys on
sunday afternoon have a good weekend
we'll see you later
bye